you
yeah
Good evening everyone. It is Thursday, May 28th, 2026. It is 530 p.m. and this meeting
of the Huntsville City Council is called to session. We have Councilmember Watkins, Councilmember
Little, Councilmember Kling has joined us and Councilmember Meredith is making his way
up here and we do have a quorum. All Councilmembers are in attendance. We welcome everyone who
has joined us this evening or who is watching remotely. We will begin our meeting tonight
as we normally do with an invocation which will be offered by our Huntsville Public Safety
Chaplain Terrell Tarver and the Pledge of Allegiance will be offered by Councilmember Bill Kling.
All who wish to join us please stand for the invocation and pledge.
Let us pray. Heavenly Father, we come before you today with grateful hearts acknowledging
every good and perfect gift come from you. We thank you Lord for the City of Huntsville
for its people, its families, its businesses, its school and many opportunities that you
have stored upon us. Thank you Lord for the spirit of hard work and service that defined
the City of Huntsville. As our city continues to grow Lord help us remain united and in
purpose. Let us continue Lord to care for one another. Lord we ask for your divine blessing
upon our city. God continue to bless us as we look out Lord and be a light for you. God
today we especially lift up our Mayor Lord, the City Councilmembers, Department Leaders,
Public Servicemen, Lord First Responders, Educators and all those entrusted in positions
of leadership. Grant them with wisdom to make sound decisions Lord and discernment to lead
with integrity. And Father we pray that you continue Lord to let the work that we do here.
Lord let it be great for a generation to come so they may see the good work that we do.
We pray this prayer in your mighty Son Jesus name. Amen.
Thank you Chaplain Tarver, thank you Councilmember Kling. Councilmembers you have the agenda
in front of you. Are there any additions to the agenda? I would suggest one and that is
after both our presentations at what would be 7C we are going to have a video we have
recently the City of Huntsville has recently been featured on Fox and Friends and we are
going to see a short segment of that video. Any other additions or changes to the agenda?
All in favor? Is there a motion to approve the agenda? Motion for Mr. Kling, second for
Mr. Little. All in favor please indicate aye. Opposed? Motion carries. The agenda is approved.
Councilmembers you also have the minutes of the regular meeting of the City Council held
on May 14th, 2026. Are there any additions or changes to the minutes of that meeting?
Seeing none the minutes will stand approved. The Mayor has no special recognitions. We
do however have one special council recognition. 6A is a resolution recognizing Huntsville
Fire and Rescue Captain Stephanie Pinto for her induction into the Huntsville Madison
County Athletic Hall of Fame. The Chair moves for approval. Second. Second for Mr. Little.
All in favor please indicate aye. Opposed? Motion carries. It is my pleasure to present
this resolution. We frequently honor our employees for their work on the job but this is a chance
we have to honor an employee who also has excelled outside of the job. Before we ask
Captain Pinto to come up to present the resolution we do have a video to share. Can we roll that
video? You know it's a huge honor but it's just something that it's you know this many
years later and just life happening it's like it's making me stop and really look back and
just be like oh. So I played catcher at Grissom High School from 2000 and graduated in 2003
and I played at UAH, played catcher again at UAH from 2004 to 2007. One thing about
my career that will always be a big deal freshman year in high school at Grissom and we got
into the state championship. I ended up hitting the game home run to win the game. It ended
up being what won the game. So I mean who doesn't dream of you know that doing that.
So that will always be like kind of like that major memory from my softball career. So I'm
you know born and raised in Huntsville so going to UAH softball games you know being just
all into the sport at the time as a kid watching UAH those girls were like those were a big
deal they were a big deal to me. So now they're of course you know I'm a fellow alumni and
we're friends you know and so it's awesome but it's hard to put a moment on it but a
lot of the good when I caught good pitchers like it just was just an awesome time. And
then playing at UAH for the coach who started the program who started the program you know
Les Studeman she all she's ever had is high expectations for her teams and they've done
well and the teams that came before me those were great players and great teams. The toughness
expectation you know made my current career I think doable after graduating college and
firefighting a whole different experience I think than someone who didn't you know especially
the teams I played for you know got to the playoffs. But if you're going to go all the
way you can't get be exhausted by that point. So you have to maintain that conditioning
and so just that physical that physical you when you're tired you've got to keep pushing
and that's absolutely with firefighting. I mean it's wearing all that gear you're you're
on your you know you've got your your SCBA on you know and it's hot and it might be two
o'clock in the morning you got woken up you know in the middle of the night for this fire
you're running all day you're exhausted. Life is life I mean you got you got to remember
we're not college kids anymore you know people have kids and in life and everything else
going on so you have to the mental you know aspect of it has to be there.
You can come on up as well.
Chief Farland bring your bring your folks up here. This is your fire family right.
He's he's in charge of the of the photos. So let me just you've heard a little bit about
about Captain Pinto let me just reiterate a little bit of it yes you heard she was ushered
recently into the Huntsville Madison County Athletic Hall of Fame from an early age. She
was an accomplished athlete softball being a very important part of her life scholarship
at UAH and served as and she served as the catcher for the Olympic gold medalist Jenny
Finch during a visit to Huntsville. In addition to the Huntsville Madison County Athletic
Hall of Fame Captain Pinto's outstanding collegiate career earned her numerous other honors including
induction into the Gulf South Conference Hall of Fame as player of the decade. Following
her accomplished softball career Captain Pinto pursued a calling to serve others come
binding her interest in the medical field discipline as an athlete and encouragement
from family to join Huntsville Fire and Rescue where she has faithfully served the citizens
of Huntsville as a firefighter for seven years a driver engineer for three years and now
as captain in the training division helping to develop skilled and professional firefighters.
In addition to her athletic and professional achievements Captain Pinto is devoted to her
family sharing a marriage with her husband Chris Boster also a member of Huntsville Fire
and Rescue and being a proud mother and loving mother to two daughters Riker and Riley. Now
therefore be it resolved that the mayor and city council of the city of Huntsville Alabama
do hereby extend their sincere congratulations to Captain Stephanie Pinto on her induction
into the Huntsville Madison County Athletic Hall of Fame and express their deepest appreciation
for her dedicated service to Huntsville Fire and Rescue and continued commitment to strengthening
the community.
All right. I just want to say thank you to all my supporters. So my chiefs up here the
fire the fire service has been great to me my family at home my parents my huge support
system they are at home taking care of my two daughters. So all my husband is is on
shift as well. So just a huge thanks to my support system in the city of Huntsville.
Thank you as well.
Thank you Stephanie. Congratulations. You know I still remember that today that Stephanie
came in for an interview to get a job as a firefighter. I remember the interview and
and since that day I will use a use a baseball term here. There's not been a task as she's
been given that she didn't knock it out of the park. It doesn't matter was a firefighter
as a driver engineer as a captain as a commander on our honor guard every task she's picked
up she has earned everything she has got and doing above and beyond. She is a role model
to a lot of our firefighters and inspiration to the rest of us on the way she handles the
task and what she does. So I couldn't be more proud of her for Huntsville Fire and Rescue
to see the Huntsville proud to get to work with you and congratulations to you. Thank
you chief and congratulations Captain Pinto. We appreciate your service and are so proud
of how you represent our city. So now is a great opportunity for pictures if you'd like
to have family come up.
Thank you.
All right moving on announcements and presentations we have one announcement and that is that
we will be holding a joint session with the Huntsville school board in these chambers
on June 1st starting at three o'clock and it is open to the public. We will be taking
a look at the growth in the city how the school system is planning for growth and how the
city is working with the school system to fund that growth. We will now hear if we have
two presentations. Seven A is a presentation from the Huntsville Madison County Public
Library. We have Connie Chung the executive director and joined by board member Doug Martinson.
Good evening I'm Connie Chow the executive director of the Huntsville Madison County
Public Library. Thank you so much for having us here tonight. I'll be presenting along
with Doug Martinson who is the library board vice chair. The purpose of tonight's presentation
is for me to talk about the library branches that are in the city of Huntsville as well
as also focus on the needs of our downtown Huntsville location. The Huntsville Madison
County Public Library has 10 branches throughout Madison County. Four of those branches are
in Huntsville City. They are Calvary Hill, the downtown Huntsville library, North Huntsville
and South Huntsville. We also have a holds locker unit at the Mart Russell Center in
the Hampton Cove area and by the end of this year we will also have a holds locker unit
at the West Huntsville Recreation Center off Martin Road. Our outreach services are also
located at our downtown Huntsville location. There we have ready reader services for preschool
and Head Start programs as well as senior services programs for assisted living and
nursing homes as well as a foot mobile that serves areas that do not have library services.
I wanted to share some statistics with you to talk about how these four branches perform
compared to the rest of the system. So within these four branches we have over 72,000 individuals
that have registered for library cards. This is over 50 percent of the system-wide statistics
in those four branches. We also annually have about 981,000 visitors that come through the
door of those branches. About 1.2 million items are checked out from these libraries.
We've offered 2,700 programs annually and have had 68,000 program attendees. As you
can see these branches are pretty busy and what I would like to focus on for them is
that we do need further support and funding and from our community in order to sustain
the support that we need to for our growing Huntsville community. It is oftentimes that
staff are having to focus more on working at a desk and assisting with questions instead
of being able to offer programs. So our hope is to continue to add on additional staff
to help our patrons and to offer programming to the community that comes through our doors.
City of Huntsville has been very generous with your appropriation that you give us.
It supports our staffing, our facilities, as well as our services and programs at all
of these branches. So we are very appreciative of what you have done for us these past few
years. I did want to talk more about our downtown Huntsville library. It's our third busiest
branch in the entire system. It's our largest facility as well. It's about 123,000 square
feet. Listed here are the services that we offer at that library. Our youth services
department is on the first floor. It's incredibly busy. We saw some changes and we opened our
north and south libraries where we had more visitors going to those branches. But in the
past couple of years, we've seen a 40% increase in the number of families that have started
coming through and using our programs and checking out materials from this library.
So I do think that the growing population is coming back to this branch. We also have
our circulation services where people come and ask general questions about library services
as well as check out materials. Our information and business center offers unique services
like proctoring. We have a technology training center that offers workforce development skills
and has a very successful tech help program where we help individuals one on one with
their technology questions. And a lot of our attendees are older adults that don't truly
feel confident with technology. And we think we are filling a gap for them by making them
more confident in those skills. Our special collections department is not only unique
to our downtown location and our system, but also just to the entire area. We do not have
a local history museum in this area and the special collections department does fill that
for us. Within that department, we have an archives that has rare books and we also have
a number of research materials that focus on the Huntsville area, Madison County, as
well as the state of Alabama. And there are a number of items there that are truly irreplaceable.
The last service that is very well used at our downtown location are meeting room reservations.
We have 10 rooms that are available for reservation to the public and on average we have 100 reservations
a week. So our downtown facility does have its challenges. It was starting to build in
1985, it opened in 1987. So we're looking at a building that's about 40 years old. And
the challenges that we're seeing most often are our HVAC system. Last year about 54 percent
of our building maintenance budget focused on having to make repairs on this system.
And it's very difficult to keep a normal temperature throughout the building. We also have a lot
of carpentry issues. In the top picture that's there, you see there's a lot of tile around
that desk. We're going to have to replace all of that tile because it's cracking and
moving as people walk around and that's going to be a huge expense this year. Other issues
that we face are that our freight elevator is original to the building and our monitoring
systems like our sprinkler system as well as our fire alarm system are original to the
building as well. And when they have failures or deficiencies, it is very difficult to find
parts. So there's long outages and expensive, it's an expensive area that we have to pay
more for to get those parts. The last thing that is very difficult with the building is
our steam boiler. So the upkeep for that is we are paying an external contractor around
$65,000 a year to maintain the boiler daily and we also have to pay another contractor
to keep the chemical balance on the boiler too. So it is a lot of work to maintain this
facility and we think that with the usage of this facility it's very important to have
a well-running building as we grow and for what we house in there as well. Because we
have made updates to the building that are not huge. We updated our technology training
center, put new flooring in there, painted the walls. But unfortunately our third floor
has a lot of leaks in the ceiling and that has damaged new flooring that we've installed.
And then we also are very concerned about our special collections department where we
have irreplaceable materials that have been entrusted to us from churches, organizations
and local families. And we want to do our best job to preserve those materials. But
with the temperature fluctuations and humidity changes, it is very challenging and very frustrating
to upkeep that. So I believe libraries are the heart of the community. They really give
people an opportunity to gather, connect and explore a universe of ideas. Our Huntsville
library system has existed in the state of Alabama before as a state. We're over 200
years old. So I think our longevity speaks to how we have responded to the needs of our
community and really tried to improve the quality of life. So I'm going to hand this
over to my co-presenter, Doug Martinson.
All right. Thank you, Connie. It is an honor to be here in front of you all and also to
thank you for all that you do for the public library. You know, several years ago, the
mayor of Nashville spoke at a leadership forum and he had said that he was a very successful
businessman, but he said that he actually formed and researched his business in the
Nashville Public Library and how important it is. So we do value that and we know that
you value the library and know what it does to the community and services for our citizens.
And so, you know, the one thing is that a lot of people don't realize what a leader
our library is in the state. We have more items checked out than any library in the
state. We have more programs offered. We have more program attendance. We have a number
of visitors every day, whether it be LearningQuest, other groups. We're open for various events
and it's open to the public. If you look at the North Huntsville branch and the South
Huntsville branch, it was designed to meet the needs of the citizens in their areas.
And we need libraries to support our growing and changing population. You know, as we have
more people come here, they're used to coming from cities that have a great, very strong
and large public library system and certainly we have that here. And any increased funding
that we need will go to expanding the programs and expanding our services so that we can
better provide for our citizens and our library users. But we are very fortunate to be in
Huntsville and to have a council and a mayor who realize all of our advantages in what
we do. So we do thank you.
Is that the end of the presentation? Thank you, Ms. Chow. Thank you, Mr. Martinson.
Council members, do you have questions regarding the library? Mr. Klink?
Well I'm very favorably disposed toward your library because I met the gal who became my
wife at one of my town meetings many years ago. So appreciate that. As we talk about
the future, I think it's very important that there be free public parking at whatever facility
or whatever situation turns out for the library. So that way it can be available for all people
and people would not see paid parking as being a deterrent. When I'm at the library, I'm
taken by how diverse the people who come to the library are. They represent the city as
a whole. All genders, ages, economic levels and everything. I think it's very important
that the library, it is truly a city wide facility and you all do a great community
outreach for it. So I just want to say thank you. Basically it's about it.
Other comments from anyone? Yes, Mr. Murdoch?
I hate to admit it, I'm not real familiar with what boilers do. If you could tell me
what boilers do and why I'm assuming moving forward you want to keep this boiler or if
not what is the alternative for what a boiler does?
I would prefer not to keep the boiler, but it does help us warm the building.
Okay. So it's a combination.
So your HVAC is strictly on the cooling side, not the heating side?
Yes. Do you have an idea how much putting warming
in your HVAC would cost? It just seems like, I think you said either 65 or 85,000 a year
for this boiler on one contract. It seems as though we could get rid of that and be
far more efficient with an HVAC that does both.
I don't have an estimate for a complete redo of that system, but I do know that the way
that it is set up it would be fairly disruptive to have to go in and change out a lot of the
equipment in the ceiling and doing all of that just from the work that's just been done
to kind of band-aid everything together right now. But, yeah, we are paying 65,000 for just
the contract for the weekly upkeep or daily upkeep of it.
You had mentioned archives. Well, you didn't mention archives. You mentioned special collections.
Yes. I assume that this stuff is treated as an archive.
Yes, it is. And how much space is currently taken up
by your special collections? Our special collections manager is here tonight,
so I will get, do you know how much it is? It is half of our second floor.
Half the second floor. Okay. I guess I need to speak with you guys
separately because I've got a lot of questions that I think are a little esoteric for this
conversation, but let's definitely connect. Yes, definitely.
One final thing. I missed your timeline for the lockers at West Huntsville Rec.
Yes. So actually the lockers we had hoped would be ready by this summer, but they changed
manufacturing facilities through TechLogic, which is the company we are using, and they
changed the model that we were getting. So we had to make some hard decisions on the
locker to where we ended up deciding on getting a bigger locker because the new facility was
manufacturing a smaller unit that I did not think was sufficient for the usage that you
would see at West Huntsville Rec Center. And so we went ahead and gave them the go ahead
to get a larger locker. The city is paying for some of it, but we also looked into gift
funds from the library side to help pay the balance of that cost. And so we are going
to have a locker with 51 units in it now instead of 24.
Thank you. We look forward to that. We do too.
Thank you. I am glad to hear of the great success of
the North and South libraries. I know they have really met the needs of the communities
there and the communities love them. But I am also glad to hear that you have had a 40%
increase in your, is that patrons or was that children's programming?
It is definitely for the programming side of it. So the comparison is we had around
12,000 and by the next year we had about 17,000 attendees.
And you attribute that to growth in the community as a whole or in the downtown people coming
and living in the downtown area? I attribute to that and I also attribute it
to the staff who have done a wonderful job of looking at what the patrons were coming
in for and really building in more things like baby story times and after school programming
that is related to STEM. A lot of homeschool parents also bring their kids in.
Well you have a great staff. So then the question is and I have met with some very passionate
advocates who would like to see a new library or extensive renovations at the existing library.
Can you just give us an update on where you are with those plans?
So we are looking at the areas of the library where we had filled out some surveys of staff
to talk about things that we felt like we needed and that in return created a library
that was very large square footage and we do know that that is expensive.
And so what we are looking at now is what can we give up?
What is the things that we could possibly move around or make smaller?
Like I talked about meeting rooms, those are very important but could we do with less study
rooms? Could we do with less mid-sized rooms?
So trying to shrink down that square footage and think about where are things that could
move up in the building because I think a lot of the survey results is first floor was
very popular and that does make that square footage spread out.
So we as the staff are looking at ways to shrink the footprints a little but also thinking
about how attached are we to our site? That is also something that we are looking
at to where is there a site downtown that and expense wise would it be easier to build
while we continue to run the library and not have to rent out space for storage and then
the building course is owned by the city of Huntsville so it would be whether or not selling
the building would recoup some of the costs.
Right. So lots of discussion and just getting a good sense of where we go and I think a
lot of people forget that the downtown library is not just the library.
It is your administrative offices, the archives, your outreach.
It is yes. So it is a large administrative piece in addition
to the library that we would be looking at reconfiguring.
Thank you both for the work that you do. Thank you for joining us tonight and sharing
your good work with us. We appreciate it.
Thank you for having us.
Next we will hear a presentation from the singing river trail.
Thank you, executive director.
He showed me how to do this. Now I have to remember.
There we go. Well, good evening, everyone.
My name is Misty Potter. I'm the executive director for the singing river trail.
I had the privilege of coming here in January of last year and taking on this role.
It's been exciting and fun and overwhelming and drinking through a fire hose for the last
18 months. So this has been really great.
I'm excited to be here. I was informed that I don't think anyone
has reported to you all in a couple of years, actually.
So this is overdue. So it's time that you all hear what we're
doing and the exciting things that are moving forward.
I'm here this evening with my board chair, Jared Mitchum, and our newest member of the
team, Scott Graham. He is our trail development project manager,
as fresh as I think seven, eight days ago now. So he, too, is figuring out all of our
trails and where we're headed. Most of the individuals on this board have
been with us for the past two years. You may see some familiar faces of folks that
you know from here in the area. We were founded originally out of the committee
of 1900, which was launch, launch 2030. Launch 2030 had a land use committee.
And the land use committee came up with the Singing River Trail back in 2017.
So since that time, we've had the ability to really focus on what we want to be and
where we want to grow. My biggest thanks, though, is to the city
of Huntsville. You all were early adopters of this entire
plan. And originally, this plan was to connect the Calhoun campuses, essentially.
So it was Madison, Morgan, Limestone County. And if you notice here, as I was digging through
some of our 2019 plans, our wonderful mayor actually had a great quote in here talking
about what the connectivity of this trail would do for not only the Huntsville and greater
Huntsville area, but all of our region. And essentially, it is establishing that fun
and equitable, safe and beautiful space and maintaining our green space.
And at that time, it fit into the Huntsville's big picture master plan.
So I do believe, and I'm very proud to say, that I think what the mayor captured here
is still very true today, almost not from 2019, but from when we started, almost 10
years later. Since Huntsville jumped on board in 2019,
our community said, this is a great idea. How can we be part of it, too?
So we went from a 71-mile plan, essentially, to a little over 220 miles now.
We span from Bridgeport all the way out to the Shoals in Tuscumbia.
It's across eight counties. And our spur route up into Athens, we have
public-use land. So we are really a very broad-picture kind
of organization now, looking to connect all of North Alabama, not just the center of our
hub, which is what I consider Huntsville. You can see on this map, and I'm happy to
share this with anyone at any point, but you can see at this map on kind of where we are,
and I'll dive into some of this a little bit more in just a minute.
But this is also, for anyone that has your phone, go to signeerivertrail.com.
And this map, not with the stars on it, but it's an interactive map. And you can see exactly
what segments are finished, what are in progress, and what are future planning.
So that has been a really great asset that people have been able to utilize when questions
come up on what we're doing. So how has Huntsville's impact driving our
regional momentum? You all have been great supporters.
You have funded the Singing River Trail several years in a row.
You have very much made the work we're doing possible.
And in return, we feel that the Singing River Trail really is positioning Huntsville as
the hub of this entire very large network and system of trails.
And the way that we're building and focusing on all of how we're doing this is we're building
from the outside, or inside out instead of the outside in.
So it's taking all of the communities on the map that I just showed you, finding the
connectivities within each of them, and making sure that there's something to actually connect
to, and building out to the edges, and then we'll focus on the edges.
But we also know that this extends Huntsville's greenways and their networks into a very large
regional system, a system that ultimately could connect Stone Mountain in Georgia all
the way to Natchez Trace in Mississippi. So if you think of that alone would be one of
the largest contiguous trails in the country. And it would be right here in North Alabama
going through our beautiful city. And that's one of the things we're working towards.
It's more than quality of life. We know that building trails is doing more in Huntsville,
it's doing more in Madison County, it's doing more in all of our eight counties than just
quality of life. It's expanding access to walking and biking and outdoor recreation.
It is creating a healthier, more connected community, but it's also supporting our workforce.
If you think about all of the companies that are moving in, and where are these people
moving from? They're moving from areas where outdoor recreation is accessible, and it's
something that is part of the fabric of who they are as a family and as individuals. So
the retention piece is probably one of the most important pieces of workforce development.
We might get them here because of the jobs, but are we going to be able to keep them here
because of what we offer? And outdoor recreation and trail systems is one of those very wonderful
opportunities to offer anyone that comes into our community.
Some of the other things that we know, based on trails across our country, is what's the
economic impact and what is that regional impact? We know that trails create customers
well before businesses exist, because we're building a trail and giving individuals, entrepreneurs,
and companies an amenity, a built-in amenity that they can build around. Recreation is
tourism, and it's one of the fastest growing sectors in the economy. Right here alone,
in North Alabama, that tourism economy is anywhere from $3.5 to $4 billion annually
in tourism. In addition, outdoor recreation in Alabama alone in 2024 brought in over $6.6
billion. This is an industry that is already yielding significant returns and only has
one place to grow, and that's up. We also know that when you invest in trails, the return
isn't theoretical. If you're familiar with the Silver Comet Trail in Atlanta, or in Georgia,
the return on that is about five to one for every dollar invested. If you're familiar
with the Swamp Rabbit, Swamp Rabbit has actually been significant when it comes to business
development in helping these businesses develop anywhere from 30% to 80%. The Razorback Regional
Greenway that is in Arkansas brought in over $137 million. How they do this is because
the businesses that build along the trail, the tourism that attracts, or the people that
are attracted to the tourism and amenities that are offered in these communities. We
know right here in Alabama, Chief LaDiga, however you say that, whatever your preference
is, and the Penhody are already driving millions of dollars into their communities. We know
that the entrepreneurs and the individuals that are looking to do something in your community,
in our community, that building a coffee shop at a trailhead is no longer a risk, it's a
strategy. That a kayak launch or a kayak rental is no longer something that is seasonal, it's
scalable. Our farms become agritourism and our downtowns become destinations. And that's
all through connectivity and networking through trails. Last year, like I said, I started
in January. So I consider that my freshman year. So in our freshman year, we had a very
busy year. We activated about 27 miles in Limestone County on the Richard Martin Trail
with our first unveiling. We also have signed now, Wheeler Refuge. And when I say sign,
that means we've put our signage and logos on it. So you all will start seeing those
a little more. And that's our plan moving forward. We did finish our seventh of our
eight county master plans, because you can't build trails I've learned without our master
plans. And so Jackson County was our seventh of the eighth. Marshall County is coming online
later this year. We also had our first groundbreaking in Leighton. So here in Huntsville, we have
also now we are in the planning process of about 62 miles of existing on the ground roadways,
side paths, protected side paths, trail systems that are already in place that we can connect
internally and start building out towards the edges, as I mentioned, that inside out
approach to the edges. We also have in Cortland right now in progress another mile. And then
Leighton is another is a little mile that will have a ribbon cutting for the first time.
And that is actually the first trail that the Singing River Trail was part of many,
I guess a couple of years ago, started planning it, help them with their TAP grant, did the
groundbreaking and now we'll go through the ribbon cutting. So for us, this is a very
exciting milestone that we will be jumping into. Some of our other planning that we have
is Bridgeport is actually the gateway to the Singing River Trail in Alabama. They are the
very first stop, our very first beginning of the trail. And then where we will end will
be Tuscumbia. So I mentioned the sign placement plan. This is very much preliminary. This
is very much draft. Please don't take this for gold. But this is what we are working
to get the money, raise the money for, is to do a sign placement plan throughout the
Huntsville, greater Huntsville area. This is actually from our master plan, but we've
laid out many of the places where we feel that the sign placements can go for identification.
We will be holding some input sessions to also drive this. But the idea is to not just
add a bunch of sign posts, but to find signage that's already there. There's huge channel
signage that's already there so we can add a medallion to it showing that it's part of
a bigger network in the Singing River Trail and get us to the edges. So I mentioned kind
of where we're headed. This is our BHAG. This is our Big Hairy Audacious Goal. Our goal
is to reach 60% of completion of the Singing River Trail over the next five years. That
means that we want to have at least 132 miles signed and on the ground activated. And then
that gets us to the edges of each of the communities we're working with along the 220 mile footprint.
Then we will go raise the money to connect all of these communities as the goal has been
since 2017. This is the short list of the projects that we have on the, on our plate
over the next five years. There are multiple others that are spur routes, but these are
the big ones. We have estimated timelines that we feel they'll come in. But as you all
know in the world of development, we control nothing. So we have, this is where we want
everything to land as we're planning, but we have a lot of partners that we work with
from local, federal, state, developers. Everyone that we have to have as part of these opportunities
really will matter in keeping everyone aligned, which is why Scott has such an important job.
So we have a big goal ahead of us. You all have been instrumental in getting us to this
part. And we are very grateful for your support and we look forward to our continued partnership
as we begin and continue to connect and collaborate to basically make North Alabama even better
and wonderful than it already is. So thank you all.
Thank you, Ms. Potter. Council members, do you have questions?
Yes. I was actually part of the committee of a hundred when this was conceived. And
as a district five council person, inside out isn't working for us. We have the most
disjointed, unconnected green ways of anywhere else in the city. Inside out, you're connecting
already existing trails with already existing trails that lead to places. We've got three
miles of green way that don't connect to anything. And it was a singing river trail and the promise
of the singing river trail to connect this to places. And now I see all of this going
on in Lauderdale County and all this going on in Scottsboro and Jackson County. And it's
like, what about Huntsville? When are we going to actually benefit from our support of the
singing river trail? And it's like the library folks, we need to talk and this isn't the
correct venue. We'll be reaching out. But I'm disappointed in what I've seen.
I'm sorry you're disappointed council member. As I said, I came in a year ago and this is
our attempt to ensure that we are connecting as much as we possibly can in each of our
communities. I would love to speak with you on the green ways that we do need to ensure
are part of the plan. I know that we've had many design charrettes that have gone through
these plans. Ideally, we want to do it again because those plans were from 2019. And I
would love for you to be part of that when we do those with ALTA planning. I'm sure you
all are familiar with them. We brought them on.
Perfect. They're the ones that are helping us. We actually just came from their office
and this was part of the conversation was that we need to have another design charrette
here in the Huntsville area to ensure that we're doing exactly what you're saying. So
that's changed. We have had a lot of development that doesn't necessarily go along with maybe
what was the ideal area back in 2019. So I would love to speak with you on how we can
ensure we're connecting what needs to be connected.
Sounds good. I look forward to it.
Yes, sir.
Thank you.
Comments? So I remember in 2020 when it was not good and the bright spot was when LG's
Walk in Hayes Farm became the first segment of the Singing River Trail. And that's now
being connected to all the others. And I think that's a great model to follow to look at
West Huntsville, which I think I've heard Mr. Meredith say that it's kind of like the wild
west out there. Everybody has their own little settlements. That would be such a wonderful
way to connect the community. So I'm encouraged to hear that that's something we're going
to be looking at.
Absolutely.
Wonderful.
Yes, ma'am.
Very good. Thank you, Ms. Potter.
Thank you so much.
For your report. We appreciate you joining us tonight.
Thank you.
We now are going to have a video presentation. Some of you may have heard that I think I
guess it was two weeks ago, someone contacted the chamber and said, hey, Fox and Friends
is going to come. We're going to do one of the Main Street segments as part of the 250th
celebration and we want to come to Huntsville and we want to show us what you make in Huntsville
and your contributes, your contributions to to the United States and what makes you special.
And so what came out was a really terrific video and we are going to be watching that
a short segment of that right now. So, Damien, can we see that, please?
As we approach America's 250, the anniversary, it is not just cities like Philadelphia and
Boston that have shaped our country.
It also is places like Huntsville, Alabama, a city that has helped NASA send Americans
to space for more than six decades.
So Steve Doocy, this morning's lunch and today's Main Street USA Spotlight from Rocket City.
Hey, Steve.
Hey, LJ and Ainsley and Brian. Good morning to you. Yes, indeed. You know, people know
it as Rocket City, right? This is really the town that put America into space. But before
that, this was actually a cotton town and this is Cotton Road Restaurant, which once
upon a time was a cotton mercantile. But today is a fine dining restaurant with a bunch of
happy people.
Good morning, everybody.
Welcome to Huntsville.
OK, folks, they're clapping for the mayor, Tommy Battle. How are you?
Good to see you. Glad to have you here. Welcome to Huntsville.
Thank you very much. OK, so as we look at America's 250, where would America be without
Huntsville?
Listen, we wouldn't have rockets that sent man to the moon. We wouldn't have gone to
the moon and brought man back, which was more important than sending man to the moon. We
wouldn't have the arsenal that we have. We wouldn't have some of the cars that we have.
Just manufacturing wise and everything that we get to do here reflects on the whole country.
And it's good for the country.
It is good. And this morning we're going to do a walk around your town. I love the town.
It's beautiful. I hope you have a great time.
And there's so much business here today because back about what, 15, 20 years ago, as mayor,
man, aren't there term limits in this town? You decided you were going to take a look
because the Apollo program long gone. What are you going to do next in Rocket City? And
you figured it out.
We did what we call the big picture. We looked at the whole aspects of everything that this
city does, you know, who we were going to recruit, who we were going to bring in, who
we needed to have come into this community to provide jobs. If we put all that together,
we came out with a great community.
You did indeed. All right, Mayor. Thank you very much. Come on over here. You know, this
town has probably the highest concentration of actual rocket scientists you will find
anywhere in the world. And this is Bruce and this is his wife, Joe. And you guys worked
for NASA for a long time.
We did.
And so when you retired, what did you go into?
Well, before we retired, really, before Joe retired, we started straight to Ale, which
is the largest brewery in North Alabama. And we love it here. And so we did that to bring
great beer at Huntsville because everything goes better with great beer.
OK, so I guess it kind of makes sense because you were a rocket scientist and then you went
into liquid propellant.
Yes, absolutely.
OK. But you guys are not the only two. There are a bunch of rocket scientists who turned
brewers, right?
Yes.
Yes, absolutely.
All right. Very good.
And they took their dream of going to space and also brought it to liquid dreams.
OK, indeed. Liquid dreams.
And you know what? Last night, they threw a lovely dinner for all of us at Fox and Friends.
Neil sat at my table. He is a geneticist. And so I'm fascinated by what you're going
to eat for breakfast. It's the waffle.
Well, you know, every once in a while, you need to break the rules and have something
that makes life happy.
It does make life happy.
And you know what? We're happy that we're here in Huntsville. Ladies and gentlemen,
give yourselves a round of applause. This is our next stop on Main Street USA. We'll
be live from Huntsville. A walk around. Straight ahead on Fox and Friends.
Lots of familiar faces there talking about the great work that we're doing. I suggest
you take a look at Fox and Friends. Watch the whole video, the tour of downtown where
they talk to NASA scientists, people from Toyota and Polaris and and restaurateurs.
It really highlights what makes this community great.
So now that we've had a lot of celebrated, a lot of good news things we are going to
go on with the business of the city. We have no matters with outside legal representation.
We do have several public hearings to be held.
9A is a public hearing in order to hear, consider and act upon all objections or protests, if
any, for removal of a public nuisance at 809 Cross Street Northwest on Salah Alabama in
consideration of resolution ordering abatement of a nuisance located at the same property.
Mr. Irwin.
Yes, Mayor Battle, Council Member Scott Irwin, Community Development Department. This public
hearing is for property located at 809 Cross Street Northwest. The property was in violation
of the State Public Nuisance Act regarding junk. Community Development issued a notice
to the property owner and interested parties. The property remains in violation. Community
Development is seeking your authorization to abate this junk public nuisance.
Council Members, property owners have made improvements. Upon your approval of this resolution,
we will continue to work with the property owner to allow them the opportunity to complete
the cleanup. However, failure by the owner to remove all the junk and debris in a reasonable
time will result in the City moving forward with our standard abatement process.
The public hearing on this matter is now open. Is there anyone here who wishes to comment
on this matter? If you do, please come to the microphone. Is there anyone wishing to
comment? Seeing none, the public hearing is closed. Is there a motion to approve the resolution?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second by the Chair. Council Members, questions? Mr. Cling.
I guess I just want to get some clarification on what the actual motion is. Is it to order
immediate demolition or is it basically to give Mr. Irwin the sledgehammer where he can
lower the boom any time he feels like it is not progressing?
Mr. Irwin, can you answer that?
So yes, upon your authorization of this resolution, we will proceed with normal protocol of working
with property owners to have voluntary compliance. I have worked with the owners who were in attendance
tonight and I have discussed with them. A substantial amount of progress has been made,
even from what you have seen on the screen for today. So we will work with them to complete
that process and then if it doesn't get completed, we will have your authorization to complete
it.
And just to clarify, I think Mr. Cling is asking, we are not asking for demolition here.
This is simply removal of junk.
Removal of junk, that is correct.
Okay. But I mean, Mr. Irwin has our trust support and he has the authorization to do
whatever he needs to if he feels like progress is not being made, you don't have to come
back, you have the authority in your hip pocket.
Upon your approval of this resolution, that is correct.
Any other comments or questions? All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed? The motion carries.
9B is a public hearing authorizing the demolition of an unsafe building constituting public
nuisance located 3108 Blue Springs Road, Northwest, on South Alabama and consideration of a resolution
pertaining to the same.
Yes, Councilmembers, this resolution will authorize the demolition of an unsafe building
constituting the public nuisance located 3108 Blue Springs Road.
The owner and interested parties were notified of the public hearing by certified and firstclass
mail and may be here tonight to present any objections to this action.
We have photographs for your review on the screen.
The property was initially inspected by an independent contractor who determined the
structure was not feasible for repair at a grade-out of 100 percent loss.
The official notice was sent by certified and firstclass mail requesting demolition
and removal of the structure by May 13, 2026.
No action was taken by the property owners or interested parties.
We are now requesting your authorization to abate this public nuisance.
The public hearing on this matter is now open.
Is there anyone who wishes to comment on this matter?
Please come forward.
Is there anyone who wishes to comment?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve the resolution?
Second.
Mr. Miller, Mr. Lill, second from Ms. Watkins.
Are there any questions or comments?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carried.
9C is a public hearing authorizing community development to assess the cost of cutting
overgrown grass and or weeds against certain properties in consideration of resolution
pertaining to the same.
Mr. Irwin.
Yes, Councilmembers.
The resolution up for your consideration addresses 52 properties.
Of the 52 properties in the assessment, the total amount of the assessment is $15,649.29.
An average per-property assessment of $298.23.
Of the 53 properties, 33 property owners do reside within the sea limits of Huntsville.
Six property owners reside outside the sea limits of Huntsville, and an additional 13
properties are out of State owners.
All procedural requirements relate to the declaration, removal, and rebuilding for the
grass.
Cutting and cleaning have been fulfilled in accordance with your City ordinances.
Property owners were notified that an assessment may be authorized and placed on their property
at tonight's City Council meeting in which they will have the opportunity to appear to
present any objections for the assessed cost.
Public hearing on this matter is now open.
Is there anyone who wishes to comment?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve the resolution?
Motion for Mr. Littles, second from the Chair.
Councilmembers, do you have any comments, questions?
All in favor?
Yes.
Ms. Watkins.
For the purpose of the listening audience, on average, how many days is a property owner
given for the grass to come into compliance before the City cuts it and charges them for
it?
It would be a 14-day notice from the time the property owner is identified as being
in violation.
Then they are mailed that notice.
It comes back after 14 days.
We have a work order procedure.
We would proceed with the next available staff to complete that task.
Sometimes it is on the 15th day, sometimes it is on the 20th day, depending on the backlog
of rain and other things like that.
One other question.
In some instances, when the grass is up to your waist, is that considered an emergency
where it could be a danger or it could be a problem in the community?
Do you still go through the 14-day process?
It would still, because that would be the statute required with your City ordinance.
You think in violation of that would put us in a legal compromising position.
Thank you, Mr. Herman.
Thank you, Ms. Watkins.
Any other comments?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed?
The motion carries.
Thank you, Councilmembers.
90 is a public hearing to consider an appeal of the Liquor License Review Committee's decision
to approve the application for a lounge retail liquor class 1 with entertainment to Barr
Holdings LLC, doing business as Tina's Lounge, located at 1200-531 Memorial Parkway Southeast,
Huntsville, Alabama, 35803.
Before we go any further with this, Mr. Riley, could you please, because I don't recall that
we've ever had anything like this, could you please tell us what we're doing here and what
action is required?
We will hold the hearing, but we also need to understand what action the Council could
take.
Yes, this is basically a vehicle that is available if someone who is dissatisfied with the decision
of the Liquor License Review Committee down below, which is part of the Department of
Finance and such.
Now normally these cases come to you when an application for a liquor license has been
denied and the person who requests that license comes to appeal that denial.
This is a bit unusual in that we have actually granted the liquor license and I believe some
citizens in the area have issued an appeal as they're able to.
So at the time that the hearing is concluded, I'll be happy to offer a little, maybe a little
guidance as to the proper phraseology of a motion if you would like, depending on what
you want to do.
Thank you, Mr. Riley.
Ms. Smith, would you like to introduce this?
Yes.
Penny Smith, Director of Finance.
Before you this evening, as you announced, is the appeal of the Liquor License Review
Committee's decision to approve the application that is before you.
You should have, each of you should have received a packet this week comprised of various information
from the Liquor License Review, the application, et cetera, in front of you.
And then I also, on the dais this evening, that was after that, after this packet was
created in the meetings, the minutes of the meeting concerning this is before you on the
dais in a red clip.
And so that should be included in the packets.
I want to be sure that that is submitted as we move through this evening.
The other thing I want to bring to your attention is there are some representatives here in
the audience from the Liquor License Review Committee.
Our Finance Committee representative is Angel Mandera, and he is here in the audience.
He's one of our Revenue Enforcement Officers and was available that evening.
And then Thomas Nunes is here as Director of Planning, and he is also available this
evening to answer questions from that particular committee hearing.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ms. Smith.
The public hearing on this item is now open.
Is there anyone wishing to comment on this matter?
Anyone wishing to comment?
Please come to the microphone.
You'll state your name and address for the record, sir.
Yes, ma'am.
I'm Alex Legg, 1455 Chaluky Road, Guntersville.
I'm actually the owner of Bar Holdings LLC, doing business at Tina's Lounge.
As you heard, I was approved.
There was a gentleman who wanted to have an appeal.
He threw out some comments about it being a nuisance.
I did my due diligence.
Ms. Tina died.
I happened to know the people that worked for her.
They asked if I would be willing to come take a look at it, reviewed it for several months,
made sure there were no issues.
There are no police issues.
There was one incident all the way back in 19.
Since then, there has been none.
I talked to the neighbors.
They've never had any incidents.
We have cameras.
I'm just here to make sure I can still run my business.
Very good.
Thank you, sir.
Is there anyone else wishing to comment on this matter?
The public hearing is now closed.
Mr. Riley, please instruct us regarding what action we might take.
First of all, of course, if the council takes no action, then the decision of the Liquor
License Review Committee will stand.
And so I would suggest that a motion, of course, it's not necessarily a motion to approve
the decision below because it doesn't need approval.
It stands.
So the motion, if someone chooses to make it, would be a motion to overturn approval
of the license by the Liquor License Review Committee.
Another option that can be utilized if the council so desires is that similar motion,
but a motion to approve the issuance of a license, but with certain conditions that
the council might want to place.
But those would be two good options that would be for formation of a motion if the council
chooses.
And just to clarify, no motion by the council simply means that the Liquor License is approved.
Correct.
And no motion means there's no debate.
There'd be no discussion.
Well council members, is there a motion from the council?
No, then hearing none.
There's no motion, then the Liquor License is approved and granted as stated.
As stated.
Thank you.
Thank you for walking us through that, Mr. Riley.
Okay, now we have one final public hearing.
And that is 9E.
9E is a public hearing on the rezoning of 97.24 acres of land lying on the east of Greenbrier
Parkway and south of Huntsville Browns Ferry Road from Highway Business C4 District to
Residence 2 District and consideration of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Mr. Nunez.
Good evening, council members.
Good evening.
Mr. Nunez, manager of planning and zoning services.
This item is a rezoning request.
Petitioners are seeking to rezone the property from Highway Business C4 to Residence 2 District.
It is overall 97.24 acres.
It is located east of Greenbrier Parkway and south of Huntsville Browns Ferry Road.
Is there anyone here wishing to comment on this matter?
Please come to the microphone.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I should open the hearing.
The public hearing is now open.
Is there anyone wishing to comment?
Joy Johnson.
I live on West Arbor Drive in Huntsville.
Thank you, Ms. Johnson.
So first of all, I would like to understand, obviously this has already been annexed.
When we annex property, is the zoning set then or is it set later?
And if it's set at that time, does that affect our decision to annex it that then now subsequently
is being changed after it's been annexed?
I also really would like to know the difference in density for these two zoning classifications.
I know C4 here usually means shops, whatever, right?
But my understanding is that C4 also allows dense apartment type multifamily dwellings.
What is the comparison between that and the Residence 2 District?
We have a problem in this city with sprawl and not preserving our environment.
And I would like to see something done about that.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ms. Johnson.
Is there anyone else who wishes to comment on this matter?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve the ordinance?
Motion for Mr. Lutten, second by Mr. Meredith.
Council members, do you have any comments or questions here?
I do.
Mr. Nunez, the area around what is highlighted, is that going to remain C4?
Subsequently, one, I want to answer the question of Ms. Johnson, but also get into your questions
as well.
So first, property is annexed and typically the property is therefore zoned through the
City Council.
The first action is annexing of the property and approved by the City Council, moving through
Planning Commission through a review of the uses and the intent of density and what is
proposed.
As we get through that process, it is zoned C4 and has been zoned C4 since its inception.
This property has been master planned and the first phase is this phase in itself.
This proposal will start with a singlefamily residential development, approximately 250
plus homes.
The development team of McKinley Homes is proposing to develop this area for a singlefamily
residential development.
As we look at the rest of the property, that will springboard some other intensive uses
of mixed use.
So you will see some retail activities along Greenbrier Parkway, then some additional mixed
use of housing and also retail.
So the rest of it at this particular time will remain a C4, however, you may see some
other proposals of rezoning to come down the line as the development continues to move
forward.
Does that answer your question, Mr. Meredith?
Any other comments or questions?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carried.
Nay.
Oh, I am sorry.
Let the record show Mr. Meredith has voted in the negative.
Then the motion passes.
Thank you, Councilmembers.
Thank you, Mr. Nunez.
We have no public hearings to be set.
We will now move on to agenda-related public comments.
We have quite a few.
So let me just read the little preamble here.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address Council on matters
relating to the specific content of items on the meeting agenda these individuals have
signed up previous to this meeting.
When called, approach the microphone, state your name, home address, and city of residence.
I will also call the person who is going to be following, so please get ready to comment.
Each speaker may address the Council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue with Councilmembers or city staff
and from making comments regarding good name and character of any individual.
As I said, we have several signed up to make this go as quickly as possible.
Please don't repeat if somebody has already said something, and we will move through as
quickly as we can.
The first person to comment will be Marissa Allison.
Ms. Allison will be followed by Alex Kimion.
Is Marissa Allison here?
Excuse me, President.
If you don't mind, would you ask when they come to speak if they'll speak directly into
the speaker because a lot of citizens say they can't hear what the citizen comments
are because they're not loud enough.
Excellent point.
Thank you.
Please make sure that you speak directly into the microphone so everyone can hear you.
All right.
Marissa Allison, my address is on file and I live in District 2.
I got my first library card at the downtown library when it opened in 1987 and it started.
Definitely a big love for the library.
Earlier today I sent a file for my son and I to North Huntsville Library's Makerspace
to get an air layering pod printed.
It's a pod that you can put around a tree branch that'll help you to propagate new roots
for a tree.
So he's going to be using that at his grandpa's house to make a new apple tree.
You will remember that several years back, libraries across the state, including our
own, began being attacked first by fascist extremists from groups like Moms for Liberty
and now that they have infiltrated the state library board, they are being attacked by
the state.
Since my fellow community members and I started pushing back against these attacks, I have
come to learn a lot about the library and all that it does.
It strikes me true.
It strikes true to me that what a community prioritizes says a lot about what it's trying
to grow.
Our library system is in an absurd position as it relates to funding compared to other
systems across the state.
We have the largest service population in the state and the city council is given flat
funding of 5.6 million for three years now.
The city of Mobile comparatively offers their library system, which has about the same number
of library branches, 8.2 million in 2025.
Birmingham increased their library budget over 2.6 million in the last two years from
14 to 16 million dollars.
This is all happening as the police department in Huntsville continues to just be flooded
with funding.
HPD got nearly 77 million in 2025, over 80 million in 2026.
That's a 3.7 million dollar increase.
Just last month, this council approved an additional contract with Crimson Recruiting
Services for police recruitment for over $122,000.
So it makes me wonder, like, are things getting more violent in Huntsville?
Why are you all giving more money to the cops?
But Huntsville's violent crime rates decreased nearly 40% since 2019.
Overall crime has dropped 26% in that same time.
And our library still needs more funding.
On top of that flat funding, the library gets from the city, the state and federal funding
is also at risk, as you all know.
The library gets about 500,000 from the state and that funding now has strings attached
that continues to force the library to ban age-appropriate books from the children's
and young adult sections of the library because of political and ideological biases.
Last year, those changes cost the library system $60,000 to implement.
And this was not funded by the state, it was funded by us.
Now the state has passed more code changes that went into effect and they will not be
paid for by the state again, but will have to be paid for out of the funding that you
all have given the library.
What this means is that they're going to remove materials.
Thank you, Ms. Allison.
Your three minutes are up.
We appreciate you coming tonight.
We now will hear from Alex Kimyon.
Ms. Kimyon will be followed by Lisa Bradford.
My name is Alex Kimyon.
My address is on file.
I reside in District 3.
You all may know I have worked for Huntsville Madison County Public Library for seven years.
I am not here to speak on behalf of the library, obviously, but to speak on behalf of someone
who has worked there who does work the front line at the libraries.
I think part of the rhetoric that, you know, a lot of the rhetoric that's been going on
the past few years, as my friend mentioned, is books and kids' exposure to books.
We could debate how we're all qualified, you know, the people who are ordering these books
and reviewing these books are very qualified to understand what resources should be made
available to the wide diversity of people here.
But something I run into a lot is a lot of folks telling me they don't know everything
that the library offers, and I apologize.
I actually missed Director Chao's presentation, so I may be repeating stuff and I apologize.
But I really want to drive home things like you don't need a library card to come to the
library and get notary services for $8.
You don't need a library card to come pick up your tax forms, print off your health care
records, fax things, which, by the way, you know who still faxes?
Government entities.
So as long as government entities still need us to use technology from 1985, you know,
it would help to increase our funding, especially since I was here at the meeting when the city
approved hiking, increasing utilities rates, sewage rates, water rates, all of this stuff
went up and library staff has not received a cost of living raise in at least two years.
We live here too.
We work here too.
We use the library.
We use all of the city services.
We want to be able to afford to stay.
I can't tell you how many people I've had to say goodbye to that I really enjoyed working
with because they couldn't afford to live here while working for the library.
The North Huntsville branch has an incredible workforce development position that is capped
at $30 an hour because we can't afford to pay this person 40 hours in benefits to help
people get jobs here in Huntsville.
So you know, all the political rhetoric is a smokescreen.
I can promise you that.
I think we all know that.
Ultimately what matters is keeping folks here, keeping folks employed, keeping folks learning,
keeping folks engaged in this city.
If we really want folks to stay, you have to invest in the library and with the rate,
the cost of everything else going up, don't even get me started on gas and how much filling
up my Toyota Corolla cost me yesterday, I will weep.
You know, I certainly don't want to leave Huntsville, but I can't afford not getting
even a cost of living raise much longer and that's not the library's fault with two of
the three entities continuing to annex property, bring folks in, build more subdivisions, build
more apartments aren't helping us keep up with this population boom on top of all the
other things that we're trying to do, not just put books on shelves, but get people
access to the internet.
I can't even tell you how many people I helped with the census test.
You know, I mean we are the people folks come to when they don't know where else to go.
Thank you Ms. Canyone.
Next we will hear from Lisa Bradford.
Lisa Bradford will be followed by Stanley Leggett.
My name is Lisa Bradford.
My file address is on file in District 4 with Sherwood Park.
I want to start by reading an email from a neighbor who was not able to come tonight.
She said she wanted to reach out regarding an important concern involving the noise and
safety issues along Research Park.
She lives on Forest Park Court and the backyard backs up directly to Research Park.
A few years ago, her son and cousins were playing on the trampoline when suddenly a
tire came through the fence, crashed into the playground area and it was extremely frightening
experience for the children and for me as a parent.
I never imagined something like that could happen, but unfortunately it did.
Because of this incident, I wanted to express my concern and support for the construction
of a wall along Research Park, both for safety reasons and to help reduce the noise for the
surrounding neighborhood.
My primary concern is the safety of the families and children who live nearby.
Unfortunately, I will be out of town and unable to attend the upcoming City Council meeting,
but hoping that you might be willing to speak on my behalf.
Thank you again for your continued help.
These attached photos, so I'm not sure if Mr. Kling has given you the photo of the tire
that busted through and broke the playground equipment.
Steeplechase condominium or townhouses have the same issue, so I want to include them
into this.
The sound is unbearable.
Cars racing every night.
People say, well, you shouldn't live in a neighborhood that's next to a highway.
While the neighborhood was there in the 60s, the highway was a two-lane highway.
It's increased to four, to six, and it keeps getting bigger and bigger.
The motorcycles racing at night, it's unbearable.
People can't sit outside on their patios close to Research Park.
I probably live about 20 houses down.
I can hear in my house with the windows closed.
Noise is an issue, but safety is a bigger issue.
Something needs to be done.
Kyle Dott says they've never had safe walls anywhere in the state of Alabama, but it's
time.
It's time that Alabama and Huntsville steps up and gets something done.
Be the first.
Huntsville's a great city.
Let's figure something out.
I don't think trees and bushes are going to do it.
I think it really needs to be a wall, something that's going to keep tires from flying into
people's backyards.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ms. Bradford.
Just for the public's information, we do have an agenda item on the agenda later sponsored
by Mr. Kling regarding this.
Is Mr. Leggett still here?
Stanley Leggett?
I believe he's already spoken.
We will now hear from Jane Maples, who will be followed by Kathleen Booker.
I'll just come to this one.
I'm Jane Maples.
I live at 103 Lyons Court in Madison, Alabama, but I'm not here as a Madisonite.
I'm here as the president of LearningQuest.
LearningQuest is a nonprofit volunteer-led organization for adults of all ages dedicated
to building a learning community through educational and enrichment opportunities.
We currently have a membership of over 600 and expect that to grow and rise to about
800 before the year's out.
Last year, that's what we wound up with was 800.
Each term, we offer 50 to 60 programs spread over a six-month term and have eight special
interest groups, with six of them meeting at the library every week.
So that's what I'm speaking in support of is the library.
We are in partnership with the Huntsville Madison County Public Library.
LearningQuest brings adults together to learn, explore, and connect.
Our courses, programs, and trips are designed to spark curiosity, enrich lives, and build
a vibrant community.
Our partnership with the library is integral to our existence in that the vast majority
of our programs and meetings are held at the downtown library.
Additionally, the library staff provides invaluable assistance to LearningQuest, including several
leading several programs throughout each term.
I would like to thank you for taking the time to hear us speak in support of the library.
Thank you, Ms. Maples.
We will now hear from Kathleen Booker, who will be followed by Wilbert Brown.
My name is Kathleen Boucher and my address is 2328 Cardinal Avenue.
My apologies.
No problem.
I work every week to serve and nurture my community.
And the library is a huge support for me to meet my daily needs and maintain my house
and a gazillion things.
It provides me with access to knowledge, skills, and awareness that help me support my family,
build overall community, and let me grow into my best self.
When I go to the North Huntsville Library and downtown, my two favorite haunts, I see
a welcoming and skilled staff that support the book clubs, the makers' studios, the children's
programs, the technical support that I would not be in the 21st century without.
They also maintain a vibrant collection of fiction, which multiplies the many lives I
get to lead.
And the inclusive nonfiction provides me with much to study and contemplate.
The downtown library also houses Friends of the Library Bookstore, my favorite bookstore
where I volunteer.
Profits from Friends of the Library support all kinds of programs for the library.
However, our financial contribution is small compared to what the library needs.
It's a drop in the bucket.
The money allotted to the library has been stagnant for years.
I hope that that can change.
A vibrant library needs to be a line item in the city budget, I believe.
We need to move forward on replacing or substantially renovating the downtown library.
And I urge you to support and respect the integrity of the library staff as they respond
to spurious challenges to the quality of the library's collection.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ms. Boucher.
Now, here from Wilbert Brown.
Wilbert Brown will be followed by Darren Barrett.
My name is Wilbert Brown and my address is on file.
And city of residence?
I'm really on Bob Wade Lane in Caledonia States.
Thank you.
I'm here on behalf of Friends of the Library.
I'm a board member and I would just like to invite each of you to come visit us.
Put boots on the ground.
Bring your spouse, your children, significant other.
And visit the library and see how and how important the library is.
I'm a college graduate and I graduated when we didn't have much internet.
All we had was the library.
The library was our safe haven.
I mean safe haven.
There was one, maybe two places that we could go.
Church and the library.
And you know which one we chose.
We chose the library.
Thank you all, ladies.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
We'll hear from Mr. Verhegg and then Karen Alvarez.
Hello, my name is Darren Verhaga.
My name is on the paper.
I'm sure you've heard a lot about the...
And city of residence.
Huntsville, Alabama.
Thank you.
I'm sure you've heard a lot about funding already.
I am here about TIF 9, resolution 20F.
It is the $220 million TIF, 200 of which is just going to the Vaughan Braun Center for
a few actions.
One of which for the library, I'm sure that could be well used.
I'm sorry about this.
For the city to recover this public outlay through increased property value, which is
one of the major areas of which we get a revenue, we would need $1.6 billion of increased investment
on year one, of which increases each year until that is met.
For it to increase through sales tax, we would need $148 million alone just from the Vaughan
Braun Center, making it a unsound amount and significantly increased.
I know the council is very appreciative of light rail, of which for the same amount of
money we could install a light rail system from downtown Huntsville to UAH.
We could also outfit the entire city with rapid bus transit, which would both drastically
increase the return on investment from those items.
Thank you, Mr. Verhaga.
We will hear now from Karen Alvarez, who will be followed by Jessie Mitchell.
Good evening.
First, I would like to thank the City Council members and the Mayor for your service to
our city.
Can you hear me?
Name and address.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Karen Alvarez, 1316 Sierra Boulevard, Huntsville.
Thank you.
I'll start over.
I want to thank you all for your service to the community.
I'm sure you don't get a lot of thanks, but I definitely do understand the importance
of what you do for our city, and I want to give you accolades for that.
You've all done an amazing job and making Huntsville a better place to live and visit.
As a board member of the Friends of the Library organization that does support the downtown
library branch, I'm here tonight because I voice my concerns for the future of our branch.
It's no secret that our building that houses the library as well as the bookstore is in
dire need of renovation or possibly a brand new build.
I understand that budget allocations are in high demand at the moment, especially as we
grow and wish to attract outside revenue while dealing with current outdated buildings, parks
and city buildings.
My request is that we keep the library our needs in that vision for the future of downtown
Huntsville.
It has been amazing to me that the new developments, the increase in the population and the struggles
with the outdated and aging building that the library's dedicated staff has continued
to work tirelessly to implement new programs to enhance the lives of our residents.
They offer so much to the people of this city, many who cannot afford to do extra things
on their own.
Movie nights, book clubs, computer classes, children's events are just some of the examples.
Meeting spaces are available as well as rooms to learn dance, play games or work at no charge.
And of course, the Friends of the Library bookstore is housed there.
There's no place in town that you can get a better deal on books.
I can pretty much guarantee you that.
We have a great flow of customers, many that we know by name.
I have learned much about the great people of Huntsville just by volunteering in that
bookstore.
And also, as I've traveled over the years to many cities known for their destination
spots, the one thing that all of these great cities have is a fantastic downtown library.
You can't find a major city in this country that doesn't have a great library system.
So since our study is well in its way to bigger and better, let's not disappoint the people
who rely on this library for resources and enhance their livelihood.
Our city depends on you all to do the right thing and I know that you will.
Thank you, Ms. Alvarez.
We'll now hear from Jesse Mitchell who will be followed by Meredith and I know I'm going
to mess this one up.
Delia, you?
Please Meredith.
Jesse Mitchell.
Hello, I'm Jesse Mitchell.
I live at 3313 Marks Drive Southwest here in Huntsville.
I'm here also speaking in support of the library.
I don't know if you can tell, but apparently librarians are organized.
I am an educator here in Huntsville.
I work over at Lee High School.
I work in special education.
Also before coming and moving to Huntsville, I worked at the Crisis Center in Birmingham
and then my background was actually in mental health counseling.
The reason why I bring these up is because I want to mention that first of all, one of
the things that helps encourage me about the city and about our library in particular is
knowing that we have these resources for people.
As someone whose students just graduated, my first round of students just graduated
is helpful and encouraging to know that my students who have special needs have a place
that they could go to receive educational services outside of high school.
In addition to that, I will say also that my students also are the kinds of students
who deal with regulation needs, who will respond to things based on the appearance and the
experience that they have in those spaces.
As we are talking about and thinking about the appearance of spaces, the age of spaces,
also I might pause here and note that I'm also almost 40 years old and if I had stayed
appearing the same for the last 40 years, something would be a bit of a problem, right?
We might want to think about, you know, the ways in which the appearance of things affects
the way that we encounter them and experience them.
I would say from what I can tell from all the librarians that I have spoken with, this
is not a complaint about the library itself but rather an encouragement saying, hey, let
us match the greatness of which the services are being provided to the appearance of itself,
you know, the library itself.
Also I might mention here, would we have been proud if the Fox and Friends video team had
gone to our downtown library?
I think we know the answer to that and I think the answer to that proves how much that we
really need to care and think about this problem and issue in particular.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Mitchell.
We'll hear from Meredith Delhue and who will be followed by Jackie Bellamy.
And please be prepared to come to the microphone when your name is called.
So the next person will be Jackie Bellamy.
Hi.
My name is Meredith Delhue and I wanted to thank the Council for letting me speak.
My address is on file.
I'm in District 2.
I am here just to briefly talk about how important the downtown library is to my family but also
to the South Library.
We live in Jones Valley.
I am not a lifelong Huntsvillean but my family has been here for many generations and me
and my husband are now very happy to call Huntsville home.
We moved here almost three years ago after my husband Peter finished his gastroenterology
fellowship in Chattanooga, which has an awesome downtown library branch if you've never been
to it.
And he took his first GI job here in Huntsville.
My family has been involved actually in the Huntsville Public Library for multiple generations.
I'm happy to continue the tradition on as a member of the Library Foundation Board.
My great-grandfather was the namesake of the recently closed Oscar Mason Community Center
that also was a library branch.
He and his daughter, which was my grandmother, Louis Mason Miller were both heavily involved
in the library.
They both served on the big library board and the Library Foundation Board.
In addition to just being involved in Huntsville in general, they were on the Huntsville Housing
Authority boards, both of them, and were chairman.
My great-grandfather was chairman of the Huntsville Housing Authority Board for like 17 years.
So they both instilled a passion of community service in my family, which is why, and the
library.
So, which is why I am now such a passionate advocate for the library.
As someone who lives in Jones Valley, I felt the impact from the library from day one.
I moved here with a one-week-old son.
I didn't really know many people other than like my grandfather, who was 90, who was great,
but I wanted to meet some more people.
We, the first place I went actually was to the library, to the baby lab sit.
I took my son there.
It provided him a safe space to crawl and to meet people, and it was just, it allowed
him to begin to explore the world.
I still fondly remember my first experience with the South Library story time.
I went there thinking there would be a couple of moms, and I went there about five minutes
beforehand and I made a huge mistake because it is packed.
You cannot get in.
I had my stroller.
I was a new mom.
I've tried to get in.
I couldn't even get in the door.
It was that packed, and it is that packed every single day.
So if you're ever at 930 and you want to hit South Library story time, please do.
You will see the most vibrant, amazing community of everyone from different walks of life.
Every time we go to the library, we see something new they offer.
The South Library now has a seed library, which my husband and I are amateur gardeners,
so it makes us super, super thrilled.
That all to be said, they're always offering something new.
The library is truly a great equalizer for a community.
It allows equitable access and-
Thank you so much.
I'm sorry.
Oh, you're good.
I appreciate your comments.
We will now hear from Jackie Bellamy, who will be followed by Amanda Nagel.
Hi, I am Jackie Bellamy.
I live in Huntsville in District 2, and my address is on file.
Thank you for having us and the service that you do for the city.
I have been a citizen of Huntsville for nearly a decade.
I am a mom.
I'm a local children's book author, and I graduated from the Civic Engagement Academy
in 2025.
I am a board member of the Huntsville Madison Public Library Foundation as well.
My family and I moved here almost a decade ago because of the affordable housing options
and robust family-friendly public services.
Within the first couple of months living here, we got a library card for each of our family.
We frequented the downtown location because of how easy it was and how easy it was to
access, including the free parking.
The librarians certainly deserve all the financial support our city can give them.
We experienced that within the first year of living here.
We were thrilled then when just five years later, the North Branch opened less than five
minutes away from our house and on the way to my child's public school.
We were at the North Branch's playground and checking out books inside at least once a
week.
We had a bag full of crafts and pens we made directed by the crafty librarian at the Maker
Space when they celebrated, the North Branch celebrated their fifth anniversary just last
month.
I have been so impressed with how the North Branch was designed.
It has a beautiful children's area with hefty pillars that mimic trees.
And I see my own children learning and growing underneath, turning pages of literally hundreds
of books and decorating the newest theme coloring sheet the expert children's librarian has
prepared at perfectly kid-sized tables.
On one of the three branches' shelves, I see a librarian has shelved my own book that I
co-wrote inspired by the iconic Cosmic Christ Mosaic.
It sits next to another book, Once Upon a Sorry by Zanea Wadwani and then right next
to a Star Wars cookbook, a perfect representation of a public library that has stories about
your local community and world's light years away.
The North Branch is where I found community in my voice.
The, I have to say, very comfortable community room with its modern decor and floor-to-ceiling
windows with shades when needed is one of my favorite rooms in all of Huntsville.
The events that have been able to be hosted there has brought so many people together.
Did you know that our public library system came from the mind of one of our founding
fathers, inventor extraordinaire Benjamin Franklin?
In our modern days, our public libraries contain computers, copiers, and study rooms, which
help us to see our potential and have resources to lean into that potential.
Our libraries have stories that light up our imagination and illuminate worlds and people's
way of life beyond our own.
Our public library here in Huntsville is essential and should be cared for and supported financially.
We are one of the smartest cities in America and as we celebrate our 250th anniversary
as a country, let's make our founders proud.
Thank you for your comments.
We'll now hear from Amanda Nagel who would be followed by Scott Nagel.
Hi, I'm Amanda Nagel.
My address is on file.
I live in District 2 in Huntsville.
First, I want to thank the City Council for hearing about this important issue.
And second, I want to express my deep support for the library and for its mission.
The library and its services are essential to what cities do to me and is one of my biggest
priorities as a citizen and a constituent.
Third, I support the city in providing increased funding to the library for renovation, staff,
staffing, improving the digital collection and at a bare minimum, keeping up with inflation
and city growth.
Keeping the funding flat as the city has for the last three years is not enough.
As I think Alex said, unlike city employees, library employees have not received a cost
of living adjustment in the last few years.
I want to touch a little more on the digital collections issue since it's a passion of
mine.
I recently placed a hold on an audio book that I'm looking forward to listening to.
It was published two years ago, so not a new release.
But I was the 54th person in line with a hold on the book.
There's only one copy.
So if everyone keeps the book for two weeks, I will read this book in two years.
So maybe then I will report back and tell you how it is.
Another copy of this book and many other books in the digital collection would be a big benefit,
but the library simply does not have the funding to increase the digital collection to match
the needs of the current cardholders and patrons.
Thank you.
We'll now hear from Scott Nagel who will be followed by Alison Montgomery.
Good evening to the council and to Mayor Battle.
My name is Scott Nagel.
I live on Big Cove Road and just want to tell the mayor that we miss him on Big Cove Road.
So I'm going to cut my comments fairly short because I think you're getting the message
from the constituents in your various districts about the importance of the library.
I've had the pleasure of meeting with almost everybody on this dais to talk about the library,
to advocate for it.
So I appreciate your time to do that and I appreciate you bringing it forward as an agenda
item for Connie and for Doug to be able to highlight the library to you as what the value
that it adds.
But you've heard that from all of the people here.
You know, the library has been a consistent factor in my life ever since a kid is a blue
collar kid of a blue collar family, first kid in my immediate family to graduate from
college libraries were always there for study or for all of that.
You know, I look at the amazing things that have happened as part of the master plan for
downtown and I'm blown away by it.
You know, there's 1500 new apartment buildings or 1500 new apartment homes within walking
distance of the downtown library, which I have the pleasure of being the vice president
of the downtown friends of the library group now to fantastic group.
And so we've done an amazing job with that private investment and that economic development
piece but I think you've obviously been aware for a couple of years now that the library
is in desperate need of the same kind of commitment.
I'm disappointed that the tax increment funding project list did not include the library.
I understand that it was because that that improvement plan just wasn't mature enough
to put into that TIF.
And I know that that the HMCPO board along with Connie are developing an improvement plan
for the library, whether it's a renovation or relocation or whatever, it's going to be
a significant amount of money.
It's not going to be $200 million like the Vaughn Braun Center, but it won't be small
either.
And I just am going to encourage our city leaders to be creative and committed to find
the funding for that project, as well as what has gone on in that TIF nine in that TIF nine
left that you're going to approve later tonight.
So thanks again for the things that you do for the city of Huntsville.
We should be proud to have you as our leaders and for, you know, helping us shine the star
of Alabama, you know, on all of us tonight.
Thank you.
We'll now hear from Allison Montgomery, who will be followed by our final speaker, Austin
Jones.
Hey, my name is Allison Montgomery.
My address is on file.
I'm one of the nominees for state House District 25, which covers a good chunk of Huntsville,
but I live out in Madison and I'm an occasional patron of the Madison Library.
So I want to say thank you all for funding the library branches.
The funding from the city is going to become ever more important as time goes on, because
unfortunately, as you all know, the statewide library board has become transfixed, shall
we say.
They've developed certain obsessions, which I hope our local library board doesn't succumb
to.
As we saw in the presentation, our libraries provide a number of services that are vital
to our community, especially as costs rise and people need places where they can go to
not have to spend money to hang out.
Building is so expensive and has been expensive and there's no one in sight.
We've got to give people who don't have much money places to go and things to do.
You can see where I'm going with this.
And I do understand that the buildings themselves are in need of expensive repairs.
However, as you know, you do also have to take care of the people who make all this
possible.
I'm here because I care about workers.
I'm a worker myself, and to my understanding, library staff hasn't gotten a cost of living
increase in two years.
And these have been an expensive two years, have they not?
As we learned in the presentation earlier, the library obviously needs more staff and
good staff.
Our library system is gifted with good people.
And the way you keep good workers around, like Alex, who spoke earlier, is to pay them
well enough to where they can afford to stick around, as Alex was also saying.
So please shake some crumbs from elsewhere in the budget if you have to and give a fair
share to these spaces and especially the folks who make them great.
Thanks for your time.
Thank you.
And we'll conclude with Austin Jones.
Hi there.
I'm Austin Jones.
This is on the chart, Owens Crossroads candidate for Madison County School Board District 3.
And I'm a member of the North Alabama Democratic Socialists of America and a 21-year Army vet
with four deployments across Iraq and Afghanistan.
And everything I know about socialism, I learned from the Bible, the Constitution, and the
Army.
I'd like to remind everyone that Monday was Memorial Day and highlight the ultimate sacrifice
of the service members across all branches and the families left behind.
These folks served in support of life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness, which none of
that is possible without knowledge, without truth.
And you don't get those without the guardians of truth, of knowledge, librarians.
These folks have endured nearly daily assaults by the enemies of truth and justice.
And still they stand.
They deserve a round of applause.
But more than that, they deserve a raise.
The cost of living has exploded since the last time they had an increase.
Fuel costs have increased over 40%.
And everything downstream of that, namely food, have also increased.
There's no end in sight for the increases.
Contrary to that, economists only see it getting worse.
Over 25% of farmers can't afford fertilizer, which will drive costs up even more.
Our libraries are one of the few third spaces left in our communities.
And study after study shows how third spaces drive down crime.
I bet if libraries were open 24 hours a day and seven days a week, crime would be driven
down even further.
And all our shift workers would have a safe place to go in the wee hours.
I recollect that there was a $5 million increase in the police budget last year.
Why don't y'all give $5 million to the librarians?
Because it feels pretty short-sighted to support the guardians of truth, to not support the
guardians of truth, knowledge, and justice.
Librarians provide the foundation of civil society for thousands of years.
Now give them the respect they deserve.
Give them a raise.
Freedom starts with education.
Solidarity forever.
Free Palestine.
Liberty and justice for all.
Thank you.
That concludes our agenda-related comments.
I'm sorry, ma'am.
I signed up to speak tonight, but I didn't hear my name called.
You were not on this list, though.
I'm Jan Hosey.
I signed up to speak outside.
Don't look through and see if I've missed it.
I don't believe it's there.
It may have been on the...
Ma'am, is your subject the library?
Yes.
Okay.
I'm going to go ahead and conclude that spot.
Thank you.
Thank you so very much.
I'll be brief.
Name an address for the record, please.
I am Jan Hosey.
I live at 2508 Pansy Street in Huntsville.
And really, I'll be as brief as I can.
I would like to reframe how we think about the downtown public library.
And I want to give you an outsider's perspective, because like a great many people, I am not
a Huntsville native.
I moved here looking for a diverse community with culture and with opportunities to continue
a lifelong of learning...
Lifelong learning.
I saw Montesano.
I saw the green spaces.
I saw Big Spring Park.
It was beautiful.
I learned about Panoply and the symphony and the art museum.
And I was captivated.
But the thing that pushed it over the edge for me to come here instead of Atlanta or
Nashville or other places, I walked into the downtown public library space.
And when I moved here, it was gorgeous.
It was light filled.
It was spacious.
It was inviting.
It was peopled by a fabulous professional staff.
It was a gateway space in the city of Huntsville.
It was right in the heart of downtown.
It was right next to the park.
I urge you to think of it as a gateway space the same way we think about Big Spring Park,
the same way we think about VBCC.
It should be a show place.
The north branch, beautiful.
The south branch, beautiful.
When I walk in the downtown space now, it crackles under my feet.
It needs to be a show place.
It's a gateway space to this city.
It is the first thing that people seeking a library see in Huntsville.
They find north Huntsville branch later.
They find south Huntsville branch later.
But they come first to downtown.
Please consider it a gateway space and help us make it a show place.
Thank you for letting me speak.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, ma'am.
That concludes our speakers.
Madam President?
Yes, sir.
Okay.
I think I got a text message.
I think Mr. Bull had signed the wrong form.
He wanted to speak about the library if I have that right.
Well, that's an agenda item.
That is an agenda item, but would you like to make your comments?
Thank you, Council for letting me speak to my community about my community.
My address is 33...
My name is Gray Bullock.
I reside at 332 Forest Park Court, Sherwood Park.
I'm here to give voice to my community for the sound mitigation wall echoing what my
neighbor Lisa Bradford mentioned about the safety concerns of the wall, but also its
good proofing and barrier for our community.
We lived in an older community, which was built in the 60s, so these homes are not like
the newer homes today.
You can hear 255 inside your dwelling.
So if you've ever been to DeSoto Falls or down at Barber Raceway Park, if you've been
to those areas, that's what it sounds like.
And so I suggest, Council members, that you come out to our community and come there at
any hour, especially peak hours, and you will hear what sounds like a raceway park or a
torrent raging river.
So I suggest that the City performs an environmental noise survey and or an architectural acoustic
testing to determine the need for the mitigation members for our community.
You know, we have young people that are affected by this.
I only live an eighth of a mile away from 255, and it is very loud.
And that close by homes, that's where that tire ended up in the yard.
Foliage and trees won't be a mitigation at all for this roadway.
And very important that we do something because we have elderly people, too, that live in
our community, spending their last days in the community.
So if you, the Council, can come out and do these surveys, that would be well appreciated.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
I believe that is the last person to comment tonight.
Thank you for those who made the time to come here and advocate for your communities.
We now will hear from Council from the mayor and council members.
Mayor Battle.
Bless your heart.
Council members, I will hear first from David Little.
Mr. Little, I will give my time back to the meeting.
Mr. Meredith.
Thank you.
I wanted to bring actually to your attention, Madam President.
I have been reached out to by the Human Relations Commission twice now on a particular issue
that they say you are aware of, you and Mr. Little, concerning a citizen who is perhaps
being harassed by someone impersonating a Secret Service agent.
And they have not heard back from either of you in terms of what is going on.
So if you could utilize your position and get back with Mr. Moore there at the Human
Relations Commission, I know they would be very happy to hear from you.
Also wanted to thank the good folks over there at HMZ who provided a very in-depth tour for
me earlier this week.
It was fascinating to see the equipment that they have and that they utilize to save our
lives when we are in need of emergency medical services.
We also had a great discussion of availability of ambulances in the future and where the
weak points are given the expansion of the Huntsville Hospital medical system and how
it affects particularly the folks out west.
So I want to thank them for all of what they communicated and it is very enlightening and
reassuring to know that the west isn't forgotten when it comes to ambulance service.
Also want to thank the good folks out at the Limestone County Economic Development Association
for their kind invitation to their annual meeting.
It was a perfect opportunity for me to hear about some of the non-Huntsville related economic
development going on within their county, but also a great opportunity to network and
further expand on working relationships that I enjoy with Limestone County Commission and
the other elected officials, including some that I have not met from the city of Athens.
So it was very educational and a great opportunity for me to meet with electeds that I share
a constituency with and also some of the service providers, for instance the Limestone County
Water Authority and other folks that operate out there, Athens Power.
If you are a city of Huntsville and you live in Limestone County, you get your power from
Athens Utilities.
So it was really good to further engratiate myself to the folks out there.
That's all I have.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Ms. Watkins.
Good evening, everyone.
Want to say congratulations to the 2026 graduates.
I had the pleasure of attending graduation and let me just tell you, it's just exciting
to see the kids walk across and their parents clapping.
So congratulations, Huntsville City Schools and Madison County as well.
This Tuesday at 5.30 at the Shurney Center, we will have a meeting with Huntsville Utilities.
They will come back with their impact study on the Tesla battery that's proposed to be
installed off of Stringfield Road in District 1.
I'm inviting everyone out.
Some Mr. Kelly has agreed to come with his staff and I'm happy to have him as well as
he will answer any questions that you have.
So any concerns you have about the battery installation, please come out.
Also on June 20th, District 1 in partnership with Parks and Rec, and I want to thank Parks
and Rec for agreeing to be a part of this, we're going to present a basketball camp that's
going to have Huntsville's very own Trevor Lacey.
Trevor is well known in the city, has won several championships, played for Butler High,
beat Johnson several times, but he is a phenomenal individual.
He's playing overseas and he's going to take a break from overseas to come back and have
his basketball camp.
We are capping it off at 320 signees, so the registration link is online.
It's on the city website as well as if you go to District 1 Facebook page, ages 10 to
17, and it's free.
And it'll be the first event at the John Hunt Park.
Is that right, Mr. Hamilton?
It'll be the first event.
So we're looking forward to having the kids out.
Also I want to say a special thank you to Scott Irwin.
Scott answers my calls all the time and I call him all the time, but he's always pleasant.
He always answers my questions.
I appreciate that.
I appreciate even more, Scott, that you're getting ready to have a roundtable of discussions
about homelessness coming up.
Thank you for addressing homelessness.
I really appreciate that.
I want to thank Brian Walker, Chris McNeese, Sarah Sam and Lily, and I want to thank Paul
Gaddis as well.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Ms. Watkins.
Mr. Kling?
Madam President, I think just to save a little bit of time, let me take what Councilmember
Watkins said about the department heads and just say ditto.
All those department heads have been real great working with me, nuts and bolts type
of issues in the neighborhoods.
And I think like other council members, everybody's district is really benefiting by the great
work that's taken place on the existing neighborhoods to spruce things up.
Little backtracking just to see since our last council meeting, I have wandered around
in different neighborhoods in the district calling in different things and covering neighborhoods
including College Hill, Bailey Patton Estates, West Lawn, Triana Village, Low Mill, Merrimack
and College Hill.
And a lot of great things have already been taken care of.
There was an area that there was a back alley that was literally a jungle and the adjacent
property owner had problems off of 10th Avenue.
I called it in to Brian Walker and by that afternoon that alleyway had been cleared out
completely and it was able to be used again.
So that type of thing, it's not glamorous, it's not exciting, but when you take care
of what you do, that makes all of our neighborhoods look a little bit better and now we're getting
in that good time of the year where a lot of road resurfacing is really getting underway
and that is really having a positive impact on neighborhoods throughout the district as
well as throughout the city.
One of the fun things I got to do this past week was a name the cat sculpture judging
and I had several entries that were submitted to me from the new sculpture that the Arts
Council placed at Jim Merrick Park and came up with a winning entry.
Minnie Pearl was the winner.
Also similar to what Councilmember Watkins said, I had a chance to go to Huntsville High
School's graduation last Friday, a very festive occasion.
Unfortunately we did have a few seconds of some people who did not know how to conduct
themselves properly at a high school graduation.
A minor altercation broke out.
The security was there very quickly to get things under control and the graduation went
on.
So that's something that I think we can be proud of to be able to let our kids have a
chance to celebrate their graduation in the way that they want to.
Also participated with other Councilmembers at the Microwave Dave celebration ceremony
that was held at the Civic Center and again the presentations were made of the Microwave
Dave dog park as well as the naming of the partial street in honor of him.
Lot of fun things.
Lot of happy people were out there and what a great celebration for an outstanding citizen.
And that's all I have Madam President.
Thank you.
Thank you Mr. Kling.
My comments tonight are going to be from information I've received from Huntsville utilities regarding
outages in South Huntsville and I feel like this might be a good way to get it out to
everybody.
On May 25th residents in parts of South Huntsville experienced a power outage beginning at 3am.
This outage was caused by a large tree that fell in the Weatherly area bringing down power
lines, utility poles and attached equipment.
Additionally another outage in the Bailey Cove and Mountain Gap areas later in the morning
was caused by a power line becoming disconnected from an insulator.
There were several posts that suggested or claimed that Huntsville utilities was diverting
electricity away from residents in the affected area to Metta's data center during the outage.
This post is absolutely false.
Metta's data center in Huntsville, Alabama does not receive electricity from Huntsville
utilities.
It is served directly from the Tennessee Valley Authority, TVA.
At no time was Huntsville utilities diverting power away from customers anywhere in the
service area.
That same day that I received that email I also received a report from Huntsville utilities
on outages in the Hillwood Heritage Estates area off of Mountain Gap and it was an analysis
of what had caused those utilities.
I don't think this is unusual.
I think this is probably true in every neighborhood but I found it interesting.
Six outages affected the area.
Four were caused by squirrels.
Two were caused by a possible transformer overload.
Three outages occurred at the same address.
The first was a squirrel while the next two were transformer overload.
Five blinks affected the area.
Four were involved in the Meadowbrook recloser operating.
Two were associated with squirrel outages and two were unrelated to any outages.
One was related to a TVA issue.
So we need to be careful about making assumptions about the outages.
Apparently squirrels and trees are our greatest hazard with those.
So just want everyone to be aware of that.
Council members it is 7.30 and we have some business left to do.
I would suggest we take a ten minute break so we will come back.
It's now 7.34.
We will come back at 7.44.
All right if everybody will take their seats we'll start in about five seconds.
All right we will call the meeting back to order.
It is 7.44.
We have called the meeting back to order and we will go on with the city's business.
– 14A, is the resolution authorizing the expenditures for payment?
– I move for authorization and approval of expenditures in the amount of $34,627,133.42.
– Second by the Chair, all in favor please indicate.
I oppose the motion carries.
I believe we have a finance report.
Smith, would you give us your mid-year budget report?
Yes, good evening.
Penny Smith, director of finance.
Thank you for allowing me this evening
to present the proposed changes to the current fiscal budget
for FY26.
On the dais, you should have copies of the slides.
You should also have copies of both the budget as presented.
This evening, changes in the managerial budget,
which accompanies that this evening.
So most council meetings, the current budget
is tweaked a little bit.
And to account for the movement between funds
or new contractual obligations, which
are unforeseen in the process, or which happens during the year
to take opportunities that are laid to us on the table,
or to face challenges that come up in the budget.
This is usually in the consolidated action
under section 20.
This action tonight is presented in the same way
under section under 20, item 20C.
So I will present the items that are contained,
including the listing on the managerial budget.
But the adoption of the changes are handled informally,
like any other changes during the budget in the fiscal year.
So economic indicators.
I'm first going to start with kind of a financial update
and go through that.
And then I'll get to actual the budget changes.
So we have headline inflation have moved up rapidly
to about 3.8 annually in April, which is burned, obviously,
by the energy cost increase.
After a disappointing fall, however,
consumer spending has moved upward,
which is reflected in the information that follows here,
as I talk about sales and use tax and other taxes.
The labor market has stabilized at a positive but low
national growth.
And our current labor market here in Huntsville
is really tight.
We remain at about 2.4 unemployment for the area.
Federal Reserve, so the Fed's Open Market Committee
kept the federal funds rate steady
for the last couple of meetings.
And just those concerns over inflation and uncertainty
around all that is happening, it's
expected to continue that current pause in those rates.
And so those rates affect us as we
move forward, both for borrowing and for investment earnings.
So sales and use tax, these are very familiar charts,
as I move through this financial update.
And this is sales and use tax collected by month.
It is the full 4.5% that we collect across the city, which
supports four different funds, both the general fund,
the Huntsville City Schools, and both capital plans.
I specifically say in the title to this
that this is the percentage compared.
The percentages laid out here are percentage comparisons
to FY26 versus FY25.
So FY25 is in the blue line.
And if you'll note, it goes a little bit south.
So it was a little bit of a recent loam watermark for us
as we moved through that year.
And so in addition to what is happening here,
which year to date collections overall
are at 3.29% ahead of the prior physical year,
we are in a really good position.
And 1.4% ahead of budget at 58% of the year elapsed.
But the next slide I am going to show here, whoops.
Let me go backwards, sorry.
The next slide, the same underlying data,
but I took those comparisons and compared it to FY24.
So that, I mean, yes, FY24.
So that is in yellow.
So it's a little bit more of a higher watermark
as opposed to what we did for 25.
Gives us a better comparison.
And the year to date numbers collected there
are at 2.1% ahead of prior year collections.
And again, still 1.4% ahead of budget.
So we're dealing with the budgets tonight.
But I wanted you to see those comparisons
to understand kind of where we land with some of the numbers
that we come up with.
So this is just the data for the slides for the sales and use
tax graphs.
Obviously, I don't expect you to consume all this data that's
on the screen.
But if you'll note in the boxes over there to the right,
that gives you month by month over and underage
for both of those years compared to FY25 and FY24.
But tonight, we're going to look at the budget.
And the 1.4% actually represents about $4 million.
That sounds really large.
However, number one, it's spread across the four funds.
But we are only going to propose a small modest increase
this evening.
And I'm going to explain that a little further in.
There's some other things moving around these numbers
that I want to be sure that we have encapsulated before we
just start looking at that kind of larger number.
So we usually look at lodging taxes as well
for our financial update.
And that is true this evening.
So lodging taxes here, despite the recent growth in our sales
and use tax and it's reflected here in the lodging tax,
we are actually behind by 2.3% of the prior year
and 0.5% behind the budget at $7 million.
So that's a little bit of a difference.
0.5% behind the budget at seven months into the fiscal year.
We are not proposing any changes at this time to lodging taxes.
We believe that this trend will continue.
And therefore, we will come out and be
good against the budget for all of our different earmarked
sources of spending that we have against our lodging taxes.
So flipping sides, general fund expenditures
through the month of April.
Overall, departments are doing well at 55% of budget
with an overall general fund at 56% of the budget.
So below budgets, we continue to monitor the personnel budgets.
You'll notice there that it is actually
at 57%, which gets really close to that 58%.
We have proposed some movements between departments
for unexpected retiree payouts during the current year.
But all of that nets to zero.
So we're taking from some departments
and kind of giving to some other departments.
While currently at 2% under budget,
every percentage will be a savings of over $3 million,
which feeds back into the budget as we move through the year.
So now I'm going to turn to the proposed budget adjustments.
So you'll see this graphic actually twice.
It'll be repeated later in the presentation.
Tonight proposal only covers the revisions in the general fund
and other funds directly affected by the changes that
are proposed here.
So whenever we make a movement in sales and use tax,
it must scatter across all the funds.
If we make a movement in property taxes,
it will also scatter across the funds.
So all other funds have been reviewed
and are presently within budgets currently in effect.
So overall, the proposed changes,
and I'm going to review these individually for the revenues
net to zero, which is explained on the following slides.
And then the increases in expenditures
are all covered by complementary decreases in other departments.
With the exception of janitorial services,
these costs have continued to rise year over year.
And that maintains for this year as well in both scope and price
as the city strives to maintain our public facilities
to the level of cleanliness that is expected.
So sales and use tax splits.
Again, this is a really busy slide,
but I'm going to call your attention to the second
from the far right column where those proposed revisions are
used for the city across those four funds.
As I said earlier, the city is ahead in the current budget
by 1.4% and it represents about $4 million.
This is significant.
However, we are only proposing a small modest increase
this evening.
As you saw in an earlier slide on the sales tax history,
these taxes can fluctuate wildly.
We saw that in the fall and it was kind of a bleak movement
as we went through there.
But then we rose out the spring.
We hope that trend will continue,
but not wanting that spending to go a little bit wry.
We are only proposing this modest increase tonight.
It will be contained in the use tax numbers
as they need shifting for the alignment in collections.
You can see there for our general fund that sales tax
is right on there at 58%, but these use tax is at 63%
for all those funds across the way per collections.
So I'm hopeful that the trend continues
and I'll be back here before year end
showing you another increase.
So as we go down that chart that I showed earlier,
we talked about sales and use tax.
Now we're gonna get to pilots.
I'm not gonna delve into the intricacies of payments
in lieu of taxes or pilot revenue
other than to say Huntsville Utilities,
which is owned by the city of Huntsville
as a governmental entity is exempt from taxes
and do not pay taxes back to the city.
Therefore Huntsville Utilities appropriately pays pilots.
Water and gas pilots, which are not in this chart
are calculated based on agreements.
The electric and fiber system, which is shown to you here,
are calculated based on a construct
that is laid out in the TVA contract.
This evening we are looking at
the electric and fiber system budget.
The budgets are presented to the city each year
based on forecasting by Huntsville Utilities.
They have come back to us and represented to us
that a tenant of the formula has changed
and therefore a reduction in the budget
of a little over $4 million is appropriate
as shown in the far right column to the very bottom.
It is a large budget loss mid-year.
And so that is, but given some of the other increases
that we have around it, which I'll show you in a minute,
we are able to consume that loss within our current budget.
However, city administration is currently reviewing
this adjustment in the calculations with Huntsville Utilities
and should we need to propose corrections
under this further review,
we will come back to you in the future.
Property taxes.
Property taxes is a good news story.
Due to the closures of TIF2, 4, and 6,
in this prior year, collected property taxes
are above budgets by over $2.5 million for the 6.5 mils,
which is also reflected in each of the other funds
affected by property taxes,
which includes Huntsville City School Systems
and for their capital projects,
and then the city has also another 6.5 mils
for their capital projects.
Property taxes were projected to increase by 6%,
but with this adjustment has shifted to over 13%
over the previous year.
The chart above shows a steady increase
in property tax collections for the past year.
So, we're going to look at the property tax collections
for the city and just remember it affects all of those funds.
So, coming back to this chart,
which I will end on, and look at that slide.
So, with respect to the sales and use taxes there,
the pilot's reduction, the property tax increase,
and then in parking, I just wanna talk to that
for parking revenue.
The main tenant of this is for metered parking.
We have seen an increase and a rise in that
with the input of all of our automated meters.
Evidently, going from coin to an actual card
has been a good increase for that parking revenue
and the ability for people to easily pay for their parking.
So, that all nets to zero for our revenues
and on our expenditure side with the janitorial services
that will be funded from fund balance.
But as I mentioned earlier,
the expenditure side usually comes in under budget.
So, I fully expect that that overages
will be covered in future.
Any questions?
Thank you, Ms. Smith.
Council members, that was a lot to take in.
What questions do you have?
Mr. Kling.
The international situation with the gasoline prices
has certainly gotten a lot of attention.
How's that impacting our budgeting?
Because I think last year at the beginning
of the budget process,
we weren't expecting anything like this to happen.
That is correct.
So, the city has been reviewing that closely
with departments, especially our departments
that are heavy in their fleet use.
The city's a little bit insulated from those ups and downs
due to our hotel contracts that we have
with certain customers, but we're not totally insulated.
So, we continue to watch those numbers right now.
They are able to be covered within the department,
the department different expenditure and line items
that we already currently have within the budget.
And so, but we're watching it closely.
Mr. Merritt.
I don't know exactly what the level of electric vehicles
and our fleet are, but knowing we have some,
do we,
is now a good time, you think,
to start actually increasing the number
of electric vehicles so that we can augment the gas,
increase the gas prices with the relative stability
of electric charging of our vehicles?
So, there may be others here that want to speak to that
a little bit more knowledgeable.
However, I know that we have considered strongly
having electric vehicles and there are,
we do have some in our fleet,
but there is an offset to both sides,
both from the access to charging stations
and then also from just the cost of the vehicle itself.
It is usually more expensive than a gas vehicle.
We also have hybrid vehicles within our fleet as well.
So, the other side to this is being sure
that Fleet Services has trained individuals
on our electric vehicles that we would purchase and have.
Thank you.
Questions?
Yeah.
There we go.
Oh, Mr. Hamilton.
We look at some examples and kind of looking
for opportunities where some of those might make sense,
but probably the area where the biggest concentration
and there's some federal grants that kind of help
with the process is actually in our transit fleet.
And so, Ms. Bryant and her staff have actually
doing some work to go and kind of look
at some hybrid and things.
In fact, when the new transit center we built,
specifically it was designed around the idea
of is there a point in the future
where we either go hybrid or all electric
and how do we bring that additional infrastructure in?
So, there would be a capital costlessly with it,
but I think transit is likely where you see
probably the biggest impact in the next few years
if the technology continues to go the way that it's going.
So, that's looking at it hard.
In most cases, the type of fleet that we have,
there's not really good electric vehicle examples
to use those kinds of things,
showing the construction equipment
and some of the larger trucks and things like that.
And there still remain range issues
with battery life, things like that.
So, there's certainly something we'll look at.
As Ms. Smith said, obviously if you make that decision,
there's a significant upfront capital costs
associated with it.
And so, obviously then you hope there's some savings
and efficiencies on the back end of that,
but you just got to consider that trade off
of upfront costs versus future savings.
But unfortunately right now, there's a lot of our fleet,
there's not really good examples out there
of ways that we could do that.
But it's something we'll continue to monitor.
And obviously, all kinds of things out there
as technology evolves like to watch
and when it's mature enough to make it make sense
for what we do, then we jump into it.
Thank you, Mr. Hamilton.
Mr. Little.
Ms. Smith, thank you for that presentation.
Will the pilot information,
are we gonna be discussing that again down the road
or if we unpack a little bit here?
Because it sounded like somebody did some math problems
incorrectly and now we're paying the piper,
but I'm sure it's probably not that simple.
So, the construct is contained within the TVA contract
and it is complicated.
And so, there are some tenants surrounding that
that we are discussing with Huntsville Utilities at the time.
And we have some people looking into that.
That contract is very old.
And we wanna make sure that we're following what happens
and that the proposed budget that turns down
is the appropriate amount that we would have to come back
with that Huntsville Utilities would pay to us
given what is in the contract.
And so, we're still reviewing that.
I am not prepared this evening to come back
and talk to that in depth.
And indeed, things are going going,
but I needed to go ahead and get this,
the mid-year budget and this proposal in the budget
so that we could prepare for it
should that be the final amount
that we come to for the budget.
Okay, yeah, my only concern is that they come back
to say, we've been overpaying y'all for the last 10 years.
That's kind of what it sounded like to me.
I might be misunderstanding,
but it sounds like you still got some more dig
and your team, our legal's all probably neck deep in it
and we'll talk about it some more down the road.
Correct.
Okay, that's cool, thank you.
Ms. Watkins, did you have a comment?
Yes, if you don't mind, can you tell me,
do you have any departments that's over budget
or under budget right now at mid-year?
We have some departments that are over budget,
but they are over budget for the reason
that I stated in here,
because due to personnel and due to retiree payouts.
When retirees pay out,
they can take with them half of their sick leave.
They get paid out and then all of their annual leave,
obviously, that they have earned and unused.
And so sometimes those payouts,
depending on the length of service
and the grade that those employees are at
when they leave service, it can be rather large
and sometimes those are,
obviously those can't always be planned and are unexpected.
So yes, but with the adjustments that are coming
from some budgets into others, we will even that out.
It is all basically due to retiree payouts.
So with the anticipation of age and years of service,
do you sometimes factor that into the budget,
anticipating that they might possibly retire?
Yes, so for really high officials,
a department head or a deputy type things,
we a lot of times can understand
that they are fixing to retire within the next year.
And we're trying to have a little bit more active,
have a little bit more active analysis
of what that might be.
So we've been looking back at what are some of our payouts
over the past five years and seeing if we can place
in the budget somewhere, you know,
a amount that's kind of in reserve
for anything that's happening.
Obviously, it is inappropriate and illegal for me
to go to somebody in demand for them to know.
But outside of that, sometimes we have a heads up.
Yeah, definitely don't expect you to go ask anybody
are you retiring?
Did you have any unplanned expenditures
that happened mid year that you just did not expect?
I'll give you an example, fire truck broke down
and you couldn't get it.
It was very expensive to get repaired
and it wasn't factored into the budget.
Do you have anything like that that happened?
Not any large expenditures other than this
general than this janitorial contract
that I'm bringing you for you this evening.
Other than that, I cannot think of any large expenditures
that were unexpected or that we could not fit
into the budget in one way or another.
Obviously things like we had a water leak last weekend
at Animal Services.
And so what kind of damage does that do?
But a lot of that is consumed within a facilities budget
that is also very large that also has been budgeted
for different unexpected events.
Is the building still under warranty, this building?
And the reason I'm asking.
Various warranties, yes.
I'm specifically asking because of the elevators.
Had a couple of incidents with them.
I just want to know is it factored in or is it covered?
How is that being handled?
So typically, so this building is not under warranty.
There may be one or two, some certain systems.
So really for all of our construction project,
we will include a one year warranty.
But then there are times where if a system
has specific kinds of issues,
we will then get an extended warranty on it.
So that kind of varies by building system
and what may happen.
In this case, our elevators,
we have them under a service contract.
But my understanding is we're beyond the warranty
and now it's just under that service contract.
Okay, thank you for that.
And I have one last question, Ms. Smith.
Based on trends, do you anticipate any challenges
for next year's budget?
Specifically, when you're looking at the pilot tax
being short, do you anticipate any challenges
in the upcoming budget year?
So outside of just general forecasting
and understanding where we are
as we move throughout the budget year,
we will see where revenue kind of stands.
The pilot will figure into that.
This obviously was unexpected mid-year.
But as we go through the year, once that gets settled,
we will start planning that into our forecast
moving forward, whatever that is.
I did say I had one last question,
but since you said that, do you anticipate
this pilot issue being resolved
prior to the new budget coming?
Yes.
Okay, thank you.
I share the concern that's been expressed
about the shortfall on the pilot's money,
and I'm glad to know that you are working through that,
and hopefully we'll have that resolved
before we move into the budget.
I'm also glad that we had the increase in property tax
and sales tax to offset it,
but we still had to go into reserves
for that half million dollars for janitorial services.
And so what was that about?
I might have missed that.
So the janitorial services, sorry,
I'm making sure that no one pops up behind me.
The janitorial services was just an unexpected increase
in the contract.
As with everybody, labor cost and then just service cost
has made those contracts more competitive.
And as we move through the big contract,
we just saw those costs escalate
and the amounts were higher in general overall.
Okay, thank you.
Council members, anybody else have any other questions?
Thank you very much for your report.
We appreciate your good work,
and you have a great team behind you
that I know has been helpful,
and so we thank them as well.
Very helpful, thank you.
We will move on then to 14B.
14B is an ordinance approving appropriations,
goods, or services for District 3 Council Improvement Funds.
Chair makes the motion.
Second.
Seconded by Mr. Little.
So this is an appropriation that I am making.
This was after a meeting with traffic engineering
to talk about what we could do in terms of signage,
traffic calming, whatever.
As most of you have received,
I have received lots and lots of complaints
and expressions of concern about speeding.
And so after talking with traffic engineering,
I decided we would just try a little experiment,
and I will do it on your behalf.
You all can see how it works.
And we are going to use Council Improvement Funds
to purchase two radar feedback signs
that will be moved throughout the area
on the streets that we have the most complaints about.
And so I will let you all know how that works.
And I would be grateful for your support.
I have a question.
Is it the type that if you are in excess
of the speed limit, it flashes blue?
Yes, and the good thing also about these,
and these are different from the ones
that say HPD has the trailers, these collect data.
So you can get data on how fast people,
what the volume is and how fast people are going
on that particular road.
Time of day as well?
Yes, ma'am.
And the other good thing is,
because I asked about putting,
can't we just have permanent installations?
And they said after a while,
people just get used to seeing them.
And so actually moving them around
tends to be more effective.
So we will see how this works.
So any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
Thank you all for your support on that.
We have no board appointments to be voted on
and we have no board appointment nominations.
Are there any nominations from the floor?
We have hearing none, we'll move on.
We have no Huntsville utility items.
We have no legal department item transactions.
That brings us to 19 unfinished business items for action.
19A is an ordinance concerning a rights of way
use agreement between Spectrum Southeast LLC,
a Delaware limited liability company
and the city of Huntsville, Alabama.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from Mr. Meredith.
Do we have any questions
from council members regarding this?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
This brings us to new business items
for consideration or action.
These items will be approved in one motion
unless any member of the council wishes
to remove an item for discussion.
The reading of each item will be waived
unless the council member requests otherwise.
Council members, what items would you wish
to hold for separate consideration?
G as in good.
Got it.
G.
Mr. Meredith.
I'd like to hold C and N as in.
November.
Yeah, November too.
Thank you, sir.
Ms. Meredith or Ms. Meredith.
Ms. Watkins.
Yes, I'd like to hold A, F, sorry.
A, F, H, I, M, T, U.
I, N as in.
M, M as in Mary, T as in Tom, U as in unicorn.
Okay, let's see if we've got all these.
A, C, F, G, H,
I, M, N, T, U.
Is that correct?
Okay, let me make a note of all these.
Okay, then let's see.
Chair moves for consolidation approval of item 20B,
20D and E,
20J through L, 20O through S,
20V through double A.
Second.
Second from Mr. Meredith.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, motion carries and we will move on
with the items held for separate consideration.
20A is a resolution authorizing travel expenses.
Is there a motion?
It's approved.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from Mr. Kling.
Is there a question regarding this?
Ms. Watkins.
Yes, Ms. Smith.
I would like to possibly schedule time with you
before we can sit down and I can get a more detailed
accounting of the travel.
I notice every council meeting,
the travel is kind of a huge amount.
So I really wanna know what's going on with travel.
And just getting an amount and not knowing what's going on,
it's like I don't understand
and I need a better understanding.
Okay, yes, that would be fine.
Thank you.
Any other comments or questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Second, motion carries.
20C is an ordinance amending budget ordinance
number 25-744 by changing appropriate funding
for various departments and funds.
There are motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from Mr. Meredith.
Anybody have questions or discussion?
This is the item that Ms. Smith presented earlier.
My question is, do I need to sign off on a managerial?
That would be really nice.
Yes, ma'am, thank you.
Anybody else have questions or discussions?
Yes, can you tell me why is this contract
being brought up today?
Why is the-
Yeah, the increase.
Why is it an increase?
The budget?
No, I'm looking at the one
about the general services department.
For the janitorial services?
Oh, the janitorial services.
I mean, this doesn't approve the contract or anything.
This is just for an increase in the budget
so that we can be sure that we have covered
the proposed increase in the janitorial services,
what we're gonna have to pay.
So we might not have to use all of this,
it's just an increase to cover?
That is correct.
But however, we feel that the janitorial increases
is warranted for this department.
Okay, thank you.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
The motion carries.
Thank you.
20F, 20F is a resolution for TIF-9 certification
in accordance with Alabama Code 11-99-4.
Chair moves for approval.
Second.
Second by Mr. Meredith, Mr. Davis.
Thank you, Madam President.
Good evening, Council Member Shane Davis,
Director of Urban Economic Development.
So there has been, I think, some public confusion
about this item tonight.
So you are not approving
and creating TIF-9 district tonight.
So per Alabama law,
there's a series of processes you must go through,
so does Madison County.
You did that last council meeting,
really two council meetings ago,
you asked the administration, the mayor,
to bring you a project plan.
Last meeting, we did that.
Since that time, we have sent to both Huntsville City Schools,
Madison County Commission.
Madison County Commission is the other voting authority
to create a TIF for Alabama law.
But you, as the creator of the TIF,
and would execute the projects within that project plan,
before you or Madison County votes on it,
you must certify that the plan hasn't changed
since it was presented publicly.
So that would be the boundary of the TIF district
that was shown hasn't changed since the last presentation
and the list of projects.
So tonight, you're simply certifying
that it is in its final form.
The next city council meeting, we will publicly go back
through that, show that to you and the public
before you vote on it.
Questions or comments?
Thank you, Ms. Davis.
I wanted you to explain that,
so the public would think it was something new.
That's right. Or something different.
Thank you.
So final approval will be granted
on June 11th at the council meeting.
We also will talk extensively about this,
about TIFs at the joint meeting.
That's right.
With the school board on Monday,
if anybody wants to learn more about that.
There was a question raised, I sent you the email,
and the question was asked tonight about the funding model.
Can you just review that, please?
Yes, so next Thursday, I'll go through that.
But in preparing any TIF district,
this will actually be the city's 10th.
We go through what we call a projection modeling.
It's not scientifically exact.
We can't predict the future
in what private investment will bring.
But what we do is we have a list of projects,
then we work with the Mass County Tax Assessor
to get the base tax proceeds that the district is,
should it be created, is producing.
That tax base continues to go to the tax recipients.
It doesn't go into the TIF district.
The increment, or the increase that would occur over time
with new investments would go into the district
to pay bonds, or if we do a project with cash
within the tax system, we'd use those tax proceeds
to just pay cash.
Kind of a pay as you go model.
Also, what we do is we project a couple of different things.
So we know the tax base, we know over time,
just with inflation and different values increasing over time.
Say a piece of property five years from now,
the tax assessor says it's worth 3% more
than it was when the TIF was created.
That new increment, increase of that existing tax base
would go into the district,
and then you've got new investments.
So think of Front Row, for instance, and those.
So we know some of those that are active,
and we know what that permitted value is,
so we know what that value will go onto the tax rolls,
so we can calculate that tax income
that would come into the district.
And then we know of areas that are proposed,
should these improvements make,
what it would stimulate based on our tax history
of projects and what they've been produced.
So we do that, we do some forecasting.
And we can go into that detail.
Ms. Smith and I have worked on that for months
just to try to figure out what we typically do in all TIFs
is the capital plan will have to,
what I call seed the TIF.
So you'll go borrow money and we'll start these projects.
In the 2014 capital plan,
we typically two or three years,
we'll program to fund that early debt service
to allow that private investment to come online
and start paying taxes.
In Alabama, you pay one year in the rear.
So if you complete something in 2025,
you don't pay tax till October 26.
And there, so we have to program all that.
So we've modeled that, we feel very confident in that model
in the projects we've presented you.
That's what you asked the mayor to do about a month ago,
is present you a plan.
So we had to go do a lot of that analysis
to come up with something we could present to you
that we were confident that the district
would be able to afford.
And it is your belief that the incremental growth
that's going to result in this district
will be sufficient to pay back the debt
on the VBC and the other projects.
We do, actually our model shows it would pay off early.
Pay off early.
And early would be in the next.
You know, it's not a crystal ball,
but we're very conservative.
So, you know, we don't wanna say 10 years and it go 15.
Right now our conservative model
is somewhere 15 or 16 years.
Under the statute, it can go as long as 30.
So half time.
And you have been very successful
with your modeling on past TIFs.
We're very conservative on it, yes.
Thank you.
We don't wanna give bad news.
Question for Mr. Mayor.
Going back a little bit,
you said the next time we would be
dealing with the TIF would be on the 11th.
Yes, sir.
I presume that means that the county
will have already voted on the issue.
Yes, so in all TIFs, whether they're in
Limestone County, we've done two.
This will be our eighth in Madison County since 2000.
So almost 26 years.
In doing TIF districts here, they've all been successful.
We always let the county vote first
because you can't vote and then commit yourself
or our taxpayers to the debt service of the projects
without both bodies voting affirmative.
So we let the county vote first,
whether it's in Madison County, Limestone County,
and then the very next meeting,
this body would take it up.
And that would be the last that we have to vote on this.
Yes, sir, you're correct.
Once you did that, we would make file to the tax assessor
that both bodies have approved the TIF district
has been created and then we would set forth
executing the plan.
And the clock starts, I believe, the following Monday?
It would, yes, sir.
Thank you, sir.
And we believe that the June 3rd
commission meeting is when the...
Intentively, our TIF calendar would request
that Madison County Commission take it up then.
Certainly, if they decided to postpone,
we would shift everybody to the very next meeting.
And we have until the end of June to do that
based on our timeline.
That's right, yes, ma'am.
Thank you.
Mr. Kling, did you have a question?
Well, just to be redundant, but just to double check,
every other TIF that we've had in the past,
they've all been paid off and paid off a little bit early,
is that correct?
We have, we've never had a TIF district go the full term.
They've went as short as six years.
It's been the quickest.
That was TIF, well, two really.
I think the very first TIF we did, we were learning.
It was a very small TIF.
It was US Highway 72 West,
just West Research Park Boulevard.
We widen from Research Park Boulevard to Providence, Maine.
It brought in the Target Center and all that retail
and all that development you see there.
I believe that TIF was only about $3 million
and it only lasted three, maybe three and a half,
four years, I'm going from memory.
But the latest TIF was TIF six.
It helped build Greenbower Parkway,
do some improvements to exit three,
extend some utilities.
Today we've put, seen private investment exceed $6 billion
and 16,000 jobs at that exit.
That TIF paid off in six years.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
Thank you, Mr. Davis.
Thank you, Council Member.
20G is resolution urging action on roadway noise
impacting Sherwood Park.
Mr. Kling, I'll bet you'd like to make a motion on that.
Move to approve.
Second for Mr. Meredith.
We've heard a lot about this tonight, Mr. Davis.
Madam President, I know we've been around on this
and you've heard our discussion.
Very, very basically what this does is it calls upon
the Metropolitan Planning Organization,
which has a very close working relationship
with the Alabama Department of Transportation.
And basically we are asking the MPO to contact
the Alabama Department of Transportation
on behalf of the concerns we've heard from Sherwood Park
and Steeplechase residents,
ask them to look at the situation.
Noise, flying debris, whatever.
But I think, Mr. Davis, you got an earful
of what you heard from the public
and you can communicate that to the MPO.
And again, we have a very positive relationship
with the Alabama Department of Transportation
and we certainly appreciate them taking a look
at this whole situation and see what we can work out.
Yeah, Shane Davis, Director of Urban Economic,
as Councilman Kling has well stated.
So the last noise study, so that's State Route 255.
So it is state right away, it's not a local road.
So we don't have jurisdiction to be able
to make any improvements there.
If we could, we would.
But the last noise study was in 2017,
the preparation of restore roads
when the state widened Research Park Boulevard
from essentially I-565 to just north of University Drive.
So it's been a decade almost.
So this resolution that Councilman Kling is sponsoring
both as a technical coordinating manager of the MPO,
we'll request a letter to Montgomery
to complete a noise study.
Part of that letter will include,
should it warrant and they approve,
we're willing to use some of our local MPO funds to match,
to try to entice and to accelerate some type of resolution
along that corridor.
Thank you.
You're welcome, sir.
Any other comments or questions on this?
All in favor, please indicate opposed.
Motion carries.
Thank you, Council Member.
Mr. Kling is always your great advocate for your folks.
20H is a resolution authorizing the mayor
to submit the 2026 annual action plan
to the US Department of Housing and Urban Development
for Community Development Block Grant
and Home Investment Partnerships Program.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve. Motion for second.
Mr. Kling second from Ms. Watkins.
Mr. Irwin.
Yes, Scott Irwin, Community Development Department.
So Council Members, every year we do an action plan
to the US Department of Housing and Urban Development.
It's a one year plan that identifies how we'll use
our allocated funding for our grant year.
So we're expecting in federal resources,
$2,104,176 to be allocated to us through a formula grant,
through the CDBG program and the home program.
So we do it through a process that started in November
that's concluded now with a recommendation
that the type projects we'll fund.
And so we'll fund your approval tonight.
We submit this to the US Department of Housing
and Urban Development as our plan for the next year.
And then you'll also see additional contracts
as we implement each one of those projects
throughout the year.
Thank you.
Are there questions for Mr. Irwin?
No, I just want you to get up to explain it
so the listening audience would understand what we're doing.
You do a lot of hard work with this program.
It's benefited a lot of families
and we appreciate your hard work.
Thank you.
Any other comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
20, aye.
Is a resolution authorizing the Mayor
to enter in a statement of work for renewal
of the agreement between the City of Huntsville
and one diversified LLC.
Is there a motion to approve?
So moved.
Motion from Ms. Watkins.
Second from Mr. Little.
Any discussion on this?
If you could just tell us what this item is, please.
Council Member John Hamilton, City Administrator.
This item is, you know, the city administers
the EMA on behalf of the whole county.
In this case, they're bringing forward a contract
that is renewal and it does the software maintenance
for all their AV systems.
So if you've, obviously y'all are all familiar
with their operations center,
there's a significant amount of audio visual equipment
necessary for what they do in response
to emergencies and things.
And so this contract helps the software maintenance
and things on all those AV systems.
Just basically the software system.
Exactly.
Okay, thank you, Mr. Hamilton.
Any other comments?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed, motion carries.
20M is a resolution authorizing the Mayor
to enter into a standard agreement
between the City of Huntsville and Wist Janey Elstner
Associates Inc. for the Garage M.
So moved.
Motion from Ms. Watkins.
Second from the Chair.
Is there a discussion about this?
Did you please explain what this item is?
Yes ma'am.
Chris O'Neill, the General Manager
of General Services Projects Division.
Yes, this is an engineering design contract
with Wist Janey and Elstner to design the repairs
necessary at Garage M parking structure.
It includes design repairs for concrete spalls,
precast panel connections, corrosion to steel framing
members, joists and traffic coatings.
The contract amounts 135,000.
Where's this garage at?
It's the one, it's the BBC garage.
The BBC.
Yes ma'am.
Okay.
Are you gonna be fixing the elevators as part of this?
Yes ma'am.
That is the biggest problem in that garage.
Okay, thank you.
Any other questions, comments?
Yes ma'am.
I forgot to tell you thank you.
Thank you.
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed, motion carries.
20N is a resolution authorizing the Mayor
to execute change order number two
to the contract between the City of Huntsville
and Arco Murray for construction services
for the Huntsville Ice Complex expansion.
Is there a motion to approve?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from the Chair.
Is there any discussion?
Yeah, I.
Mr. Meredith.
I don't like the pizza kitchen thing,
but there's no sense in offering up an amendment
that's not gonna pass, so I just wanted to hold it
so I could, well you'll find out in a second.
Okay.
Could we have a description of the pizza kitchen
and what that's all about?
Council members, if I could,
let me kind of explain what's going on there.
So first off, this change order is within
the budgeted contingency funds that we have on the project.
But obviously that kind of change in scope looks unusual,
but I think it's a good example,
and particularly as we were talking about budgets
and we're gonna have a lot more discussion
about budget coming up and how a number of our entities
that are operated outside of city departments
need our assistance in terms of operating budget.
What you'll notice when you go through that process
is the Iceplex is not on that list.
The Iceplex has never needed a subsidy
to help balance its operating budget.
We obviously invest in the capital,
they also do some fundraising and assist with that.
But their operating budget,
they operate 100% off their earned revenues.
One of the things that this project does,
obviously it significantly expands their capacity,
part of that is an arena that we also expect
to contribute significantly to tourism.
But we have in place here a very good board,
and obviously I think the mayor's got one or two appointments,
but the majority of the folks there
are appointed by the city council.
And we challenge them continuously,
like we do all the boards are finding ways
to continue to earn their revenues
and fund their operations off of earned revenues
to the extent possible.
One of the things that they've done
and why you see this as a change order
instead of in the original scope
is since this project got completed in terms of design
and got under construction,
they've done a lot of work
with looking at their food service operations.
We've challenged them to do that,
both internal to the Iceplex,
but we also challenged them to look at how
they could use their food service capacity
to improve food service to other areas of John Hunt Park.
So they're specifically looking at how they can start
sateliting food service into the Spencer Sports Complex
and some other parts of John Hunt Park
that contributes to that tourism and things.
They've actually have brought on a new food service manager
in one of the areas where they have found
significant demand and they've experimented
with the equipment they have on hand
to how they can deliver pizzas,
one of the food service items that's done very, very well,
but they really need new equipment
and a kitchen designed properly for it
to do the volume that will occur inside that arena.
And so that's why you see one of the previously designed
and in the original scope concession stand areas
that we have recommended they changed
to increase that capacity.
So this significantly improves their capacity
for food service inside the venue,
but also allows them to partner with us
and continue to earn those revenues.
That's what this is about.
Obviously it's a little bit unusual.
This type of change over comes to you.
So I think the questions and the scrutiny
is absolutely appropriate,
but this is an example where one of our city venues
that we've chosen to operate with a board
who hires the employees and operates that venue
on our behalf is actually doing a very, very good job
with earned revenues.
And this is just another way to continue to expand on that.
So really I would argue
that you're investing in success there.
Sometimes we have to invest in things
that aren't going well to try and improve them.
And this is a case where you're actually investing
in success and we anticipate their financial success
to continue and only to get better
as we finish out this project.
So that's where that is.
Happy to take on any other questions.
Thank you for that explanation.
Questions from Mr. Hamilton or other discussion?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Nay.
Mr. let the record show Mr. Meredith has voted
in the negative and the resolution is approved.
20T is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter
into agreement between the city of Huntsville
and Lambert contract for the city of Huntsville streets,
concrete and ADA upgrades fiscal year 2026 phase two.
Is there a motion for Mr. Little second from the chair?
Mr. Hamilton.
Yes, council members.
The item before you is specifically for what I refer to
is the concrete surrounding the streets
that we're gonna repave.
We'll take on the repaving specifically at the next item,
but T and U obviously go together
and you all have seen that before.
I would tell you just as a quick aside,
I've been working with legal and looking,
I think in the future we'll be able to bring these
to you together under a single item,
but for tonight they're still separate items
on your agenda.
So as we, each time we do a phase of our repaving program,
in this case it's 62 streets,
the way in which we are working to achieve ADA compliance
in all of our streets as we blinked it,
link that program to our repaving.
So every time we repave a street,
we are obligated to go in and fix all the surrounding
concrete, which equals the pedestrian infrastructure
and those kinds of things.
We also look at drainage systems.
Sometimes there are inlets and stuff that need to be rebuilt
or whatever it may be.
So you're looking at all the things associated
with the street, not just the asphalt for the cars,
but also the curbs and the drainage systems
as well as the sidewalks, ADA ramps, those kinds of things.
So this contract is specifically to fix all the surrounding
concrete on streets that we're gonna repave
with your approval.
So that's what this first contract is.
Great, questions from Mr. Hamilton.
I do.
Mr. Hamilton, can you give some examples
of where we didn't have ADA compliant curbs
or how bikes can ride and you gotta jump a curb
or fit there in a wheelchair?
Absolutely.
So there are a lot of the neighborhoods that are older.
Okay, the intersection in the neighborhood where I live,
there is no ADA ramp whatsoever.
So obviously when it's time to repave that street,
we're gonna come in and put in all the ADA ramps.
Whether anybody's asked for it or not,
that will happen automatically.
Let me come back to also in a minute
where we may find a specific issue
where a citizen needs us to do something
because we will do stuff outside of that program.
But for this specifically,
whether anybody's asked for it or not,
we're gonna bring them all to compliance.
So we have a lot of older neighborhoods
where there is no ADA ramp at all.
And so you're installing all new.
The other thing that has occurred is in some cases
since neighborhoods were built out,
some of the standards have changed.
And so while they were compliant
at the time they were built, they're no longer compliant.
And so we fix those situations as well.
So some of the width of sidewalks,
the allowable side slopes, all those kinds of things,
most standards have changed over the years.
And so everything we do is in accordance
with the new standards.
So in some cases we've got to do a significant rebuild
of something that was previously compliant
but just fell out of compliance with the change in the law.
We do also, this is specifically,
our repaving program really gets executed in two ways.
Primarily when you see these,
and this is phase two for this fiscal year,
we typically will do three, sometimes four phases.
And that's where we've gone out, evaluated all the streets,
identified a specific set, in this case,
62 streets that need to be repaved
and do all those repairs.
We also have a periodic contract that public works has
so that when something comes up
where there's a specific problem in a street,
we don't have to wait till the next phase.
They can send them out and just do that one street.
Or if we have a citizen, maybe somebody moves in
who's wheelchair-bound and it's not ADA compliant
around their neighborhood.
And so we'll identify that, work with them
and go and fix that kind of out of cycle
in order to accommodate that.
And there's other things like that where we may come in
where there's a specific concern for a citizen.
So that can happen as well.
But the primary way in which we're getting our entire city
up to ADA compliance is through repaving.
So every single year,
however many hundreds of streets get repaved,
they will all be brought up to current standards.
I wanna say first, thank you.
And especially Chris McNeese and his department,
because I noticed this throughout the city.
And I get a lot of phone calls.
People are complaining because they're like,
you got the roads tore up, we can't get through.
And one of the things I try to explain to them is
we're trying to bring it up to compliance.
We're trying to get it handicapped accessible
at the same time.
But my last question I have for you,
if you would just explain,
I understand but some of the residents don't.
They think that you're supposed to strike
the residential roads.
And one of the things that I asked Chris,
because I didn't recall any roads in my community
having strikes.
And Chris said, that's something that you don't do.
Can you explain that please for people who are listening?
And I'll tell you, that's something that really,
so while public works and under Chris McNeese's leadership,
they execute the repaving.
They also do that in conjunction with other departments.
And so all of those striping and signage
and those kinds of standards are really overseen
by the traffic engineering department.
So one of the things that will happen,
because sometimes we may as part of a repaving
actually reconfigure a road, change the number of lanes
or whatever it may be.
Traffic engineering is who will really kind of
lead the design of that and bring a new striping plan.
And that's where they have stripes versus streets
with no stripes is largely based on how it's classified.
So a residential street below a certain speed limit
is not gonna have center stripes and things.
When you start getting up to higher speed limits
or higher traffic counts and they classify the road
differently, then that's what it'll call for those.
And those are all mostly established by federal standards
that traffic engineering understands
and enforces those things.
Thank you so much.
Are there any other questions specific
to the concrete and ADA upgrades?
Yes.
I'm all for the concrete ADA upgrade.
No problem with that.
Is there a way somehow we can coordinate better
and shorten the delay time that goes
from when all the concrete work is done,
you're having to wait for a long period of time
until the asphalt comes.
There's a gentleman, for example,
I think over on Cypress Avenue,
the concrete work was done and they've been waiting
a long time over in the Mayfair neighborhood,
concrete work is done and they're still waiting
for the asphalt.
Is there some sort of a list or way
that can be coordinated a little bit faster?
And we'll work on that.
It is obviously you got two different companies
and they've got to follow each other.
And so sometimes there's mobilization challenges
or whatever, sometimes weather could impact it as well.
But I'll talk to the staff about that
and see what we can do to kind of force a faster,
faster coming.
Thank you.
Anybody else?
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
Motion carries.
And then we will end with 20-U resolution authorizing
Mayor to enter agreement between the city of Huntsville
and Rogers Group for the city of Huntsville
streets resurfacing.
Chair makes the motion.
Second.
Second for Mr. Little.
So this is the resurfacing contract phase two.
And this is the asphalt for those same streets
that were associated with the concrete contract
you just approved.
How many phases are there?
Well, it kind of varies.
Typically we'll do three per year, sometimes four,
kind of depending on how things play out.
Any comments?
Anybody?
All right.
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
Motion carries.
That concludes 20.
We will have item 21.
These items are for introduction.
Thank you to everybody who helped us get through that.
These items in 21 are introduction only.
They will be considered at the June 11th meeting.
21A is an introduction of an ordinance amending
chapter 15, article three, division five, section 15
of the code of ordinances for the city of Huntsville
regarding license fees.
21B is introduction of an ordinance annexing
24.67 acres of land lying on the north side
of University Drive east of Providence, Maine.
21C is introduction of an ordinance annexing
1.98 acres of land lying on the north side of Capshaw Road
west of Hempwell, Triana Highway.
21D is introduction of an ordinance to declare
certain property surplus and no longer needed
for municipal use.
Again, those items will be considered by council
at the June 11th meeting.
This now brings us to the second roster, public comments.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons
wishing to address the council on matters relating
to city business, whether or not such items
are on the meeting agenda.
Speakers have signed up previously, and when called,
please approach the microphone, state your name,
home address, and city of residence.
I will also call the person who will be coming after,
so please get ready to come up.
Each speaker may address the council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into dialogue
with council members or city staff,
and from making comments regarding good name and character
of any individual.
So that's it.
The first speaker is Timothy Jones.
Timothy Jones will be followed by Nick Freebold.
Good evening, everybody.
My name is Timothy Jones, 209 Denton Tree Square,
Huntsville.
Thank you.
I'm the owner of the North Alabama Wardogs.
If you didn't know, we had a semi-pro basketball team.
We're going into our seventh season.
Over the last six years, we have,
we had over 10 players that went overseas
and got other professional opportunities.
We always say we more than basketball.
So our biggest thing right now, we have facility issues.
Trying to, we were trying to make a move to Huntsville.
We've been playing out of Madison,
and we've been having, you know,
trying to work with the Huntsville City Schools
and the cottages.
And right now we need a home.
So, and then also we have a,
the N1 mixed-stage street ball tour team
is trying to come to Huntsville.
They want to partner up with the North Alabama Wardogs
and bring their,
bring their entertainment basketball styles to Huntsville.
And we need a location for the event.
So I'm looking for support,
see how Huntsville can help support that event.
And also for our season, our seasons,
the North Alabama Wardogs season begins in October.
So, so just like I said, we're going into our seventh season.
I'm looking for the support and thank you for your time.
Thank you, sir.
The next person to speak will be Nick Freebold.
Mr. Freebold will be followed by Walter Walker.
I am Nick Freebold.
I live in district four of Huntsville.
There's a common misconception that immigrants
are either legal or illegal.
As someone who has personally navigated
the immigration system, I can promise you,
it is not that simple.
Before I married my wife, she was living in Malaysia.
We went through the K-1 visa process
to bring her and her daughter to America.
When she arrived, we got married within 90 days
as required by the K-1 visa.
She came here illegally and we found,
we followed the rules.
But the moment we signed the marriage document,
her K-1 visa expired.
The K-1 visa is only valid until the day we get married.
After marriage, we had to immediately apply
for permanent residence, also known as green card.
But green cards are not processed quickly.
For us, it took 10 months.
During those 10 months, my wife and stepdaughter
did not have legal status.
They were not here illegally,
but they had no legal protections either.
They were under a legal gray area
of having authorized stay while their green cards processed.
What this meant was that they were allowed to stay here
until the moment they're told to leave.
What this meant was that absolutely any interaction
with ICE or police agencies working with ICE
could result to my wife and stepdaughter
being forcibly separated from me.
They would be deported and sent to a country
where our marriage is illegal.
I want to emphasize that we followed every step
as designed by US immigration system.
But my family could have still been grabbed off the streets
by ICE agents at any time for any reason,
even without committing any crimes.
It's not just hardened criminals
at risk of being taken by ICE.
It's every single immigrant family.
Do you know what it's like to live every single day in fear
that today could be the day
that your wife and child is taken from you?
We had to live in fear every single day
for 10 months straight because of the terror
being brought by ICE raiding our cities.
Is anyone here willing to stand up against ICE
and protect our families?
Or are you on the side of ICE
who is terrorizing the people that you represent?
Thank you.
We'll hear now from Walter Walker.
Walter Walker will be followed by Joy Johnson.
It's Walter Walker here.
We will move on then to Joy Johnson.
And following Joy Johnson, we will hear from Howard Ross.
Joy Johnson, I live on West Arbor Drive in Huntsville.
I wanna start by talking about,
I went to Planning Commission this week.
And I think, I'm kinda glad the mayor's gone
because I would like you guys
to take the Planning Commission over just the same way
that you tried to do sustainability.
It's time for that to be a much more democratic process,
much more representative of people
instead of monied interests.
And at the same time,
the Sustainability Commission or committee
or whatever it's called,
I think that they would really appreciate
being involved in the Planning Commission business.
That's what they're there for,
to talk about what do we need to do moving forward
as a city.
And they're not informed, they're not invited,
they're not nothing, and I think they should also be
on the committees within the Planning Commission,
the zoning guys and all of those guys.
About electric vehicles, I have to say that,
yeah, those big trucks that you won't be able
to put on electricity, this country runs on diesel.
And the kind of oil that you need to make diesel from,
we have to import.
So everything is about to change.
Hold on to your you know what.
Thank you.
Thank you, Joy.
And now we will hear from Howard Ross.
Howard Ross will be followed by McKinley Dunford.
Hi, I'm here again for the trespassing at 6016.
Your name and address.
Howard Ross, 2167 Excalibur Drive here in Huntsville.
I'm here again on the continuing trespassing
against Mark and Patty Culbertson
at 6016 Ellington Drive.
They took possession in good faith of the property
after a sheriff's sale, and the previous owner
filed to redeem the property and immediately went
and filed or had the police come to the property,
accusing them of being squatters,
and the police came and determined
that they weren't squatting,
that they were lawfully in possession,
and subsequently the previous owner filed a eviction
against them, and before there was,
and there's never been an order or rid of possession
for that possession for the previous owner,
and they came and began, while the Culbertsons
were visiting folks and not on the property,
came and started removing their property and ousting them,
and causing damages, and we called the police,
I called the police, who came over to complain
against the trespassing, and the police,
instead of stopping it, encouraged them to keep trespassing
and remove their property.
I have brought this before the city council before
to find out how to handle this,
and have gotten no answers or nothing that was pertinent.
There was something about that the former owners
weren't allowed to trespass, well that's not true.
I have this case, Tate versus State,
that a lawyer gave to me in the,
to do with Five Southern Report, or 254,
that states that burglary like trespassing
is an offense against the possession,
and hence the test for the purpose of determining
to whom the ownership of the premises should be had,
laid, excuse me, is in an indictment,
is not the title, but the occupancy or possession
at the time the offense was commenced.
Since the culprits were in possession
at the time that this was commenced,
the fact that they don't have the title,
and so it also says the title does not excuse them
from trespassing.
The last time I was here, the city administrator
said that they complained that the culprits had filed,
did not include trespassing, they went to trespassing
at the front desk of Wheeler Avenue,
and they were not allowed, were not permitted
to file a complaint for trespassing,
and I believe they have a right to file that,
and apparently it's a police cover-up,
and we need to find out at least who is the,
we have an elected official from that district
to find out how we can get, find out
of whether there's a cover-up by the police,
just like there's been indicator against the gentleman
who was shot while they were repossessing his car.
Don't know who the commissioner or who the councilman is,
who's been elected to handle this,
but we do need to find out what we can do about this.
It's a civil rights violation.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
We will now hear from McKinley Dunford,
who will be followed by Angela Somerset.
McKinley Dunford, we will move on to Angela Somerset,
who will be followed by Elliot White.
Is Dr. Somerset here?
There.
Good evening, I am Dr. Angela Somerset,
and I reside at 9 Chalkstone Street in Huntsville.
Thank you.
So I have three very brief concerns.
The first is the one about the PFAS
through Huntsville Utilities, which of course,
basically stands for Forever Chemicals.
So I see where Huntsville Utilities
has filed a lawsuit in regards to that,
and of course the EPA is standardizing
when all that occurred, so that would start in 2024,
but compliance issues would start in 2029.
But because of the health-related risks,
and because Huntsville Utilities has in their
mission statement that they want to do the right thing,
transparency, accountability would be imperative.
The second one I wanted to address was with Ms. Penny,
when she stated that the utility money
was approved to be used for fiber.
I'm not aware that in the TVA contract that that was the case.
Now even though Huntsville Utilities
uses some fiber for substations,
I don't think automated meters
would require fiber of that size.
So I would love to be able to look at that report,
because I still say and continue to say
that Huntsville Utilities is going to be an issue
in regards to money as well as liability for this city.
Thirdly, I had a citizen that approached me
over the memorial holiday,
where she was a realtor as well,
and sold a home to someone, and Huntsville Utilities
got this homeowner's meter mixed up with the model home
and was charging them.
And so the citizen went in, tried to get it corrected,
could not get it corrected, and it took a call from me
to one of their VPs in order to get it straightened out,
which we did, and the citizen ended up with a refund.
So what I would like to see happen more so
is to see a greater action from our council,
making our boards more accountable,
making them come in with reports.
We are taking too much at face value,
because first of all, most utility companies
would have taken out a bond,
but that means you would have had to petition the FCC.
So since you didn't wanna do that as Huntsville Utilities,
then guess what, you use our electric money,
and it's gonna become a sinkhole for this city.
That's all I gotta say.
Thank you.
We'll now hear from Elliot White,
who will be followed by David Snyder.
Is Elliot White here?
We will move on then to David Snyder,
who will be followed by our last speaker, Yolanda Cotter.
Howdy.
Hello.
My name is David Snyder.
My information is written correctly on the sheet.
I live in Huntsville.
Thank you.
I am aghast at the disgrace and shame
that has transpired at tonight's city council session.
Having been threatened with removal
during a second roster comment
for attempting to use the last 30 seconds,
30 seconds of my time with a moment of silence,
honoring 120 dead children,
only to watch city council spend several minutes
showing Fox News celebrate Huntsville
being a cotton town as much or more
than our well-known space exploration program.
And history of that, it was disgusting
and a flagrant display of a lack of regard
for particular members of our communities.
Make no mistake, there is a strong tie-in
between the state defunding our public libraries
and Fox News coming here to celebrate
Huntsville being a former cotton town.
This is why we need a black history museum.
We have an excellent opportunity to create,
as several members of Omega Psi Phi
have mentioned previously, a black history museum
that includes our black community's contributions
to space exploration and the challenges those people faced
and the challenges black engineers still do.
Thank you.
And finally, Yolanda Cottle.
Is Yolanda Cottle here?
She's not here.
Then that concludes our second roster communications.
Is there a motion?
Move to adjourn.
The meeting is adjourned at 8.59.